[Music]
hey guys welcome to this complete
angular tutorial angular is a
full-fledged JavaScript front-end
framework used to create single page
applications applications like Gmail
upwork Nike and Forbes among others are
built using angular
now there's a great demand for angular
developers in the market today so if you
wish to learn angular then you're in the
right place this complete tutorial will
introduce to you the fundamental
concepts of this framework first we'll
start off by understanding what exactly
angular is
then I'll help you create a simple hello
world application and teach the basic
file system and libraries of the
application then we learn about the
basic building blocks of angular that is
components after that we'll dive into
advanced topics like angular dependency
injection forms Services angular
bootstrap and angular routing after that
we'll compare angular with other
front-end JavaScript libraries like
react and view next we'll have a look at
what's new with the latest angular
version that is angular 10. and lastly
I'll present to you angular interview
questions that will help you crack your
next interview
but before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our Channel already make
sure to click the Subscribe button and
the bell icon to never miss an update
in this session we're gonna cover the
topic of what is angular
I'm sure all of you use mobile and web
applications be it from social media to
healthcare e-commerce and net banking
these apps are used by billions of
people across the globe now the main
reason we use these apps is that they
offer seamless user experience and
interface but how would it developed
provide such reliability one of the
Frameworks that is widely used to build
such robust apps is angular so let's
dive into the session now so here is a
list of topics that we're going to be
covering first up we'll see why angular
was introduced then what is angular
features of angular
angular architecture advantages and
limitations of angular
the learning curve of angular and
finally we look at some of the companies
that deploy angular so without further
delay let's begin
why angular now JavaScript is the most
commonly used client-side scripting
language it is written into HTML
documents enabling interactions with web
pages in many unique ways
so as a relatively easy to learn
language with almost pervasive support
it is exceptionally well suited to
develop modern applications but the
question arises
is Javascript ideal for developing
single page applications that require
modularity testability and other
features perhaps not however we have a
variety of Frameworks and libraries
designed to help us with such thing with
respect to front-end development angular
and JavaScript together bring in
structure and consistency to your web
applications and also provide
scalability and maintainability
and angular is specifically developed
for single page applications so now the
question arises what exactly is angular
angle angular is an
old JavaScript framework written
completely in typescript
now it was primarily aimed to develop
single page applications and is
maintained by Google
angular as a framework provides a few
advantages while also providing a
standard structure for Developers
designed for web desktop and mobile
platforms if you have a doubt here as to
what exactly single page applications
are let me help you with that now these
single page applications are basically
applications that get loaded just once
so the main page gets loaded onto your
browser so any further interactions does
not lead to loading of subsequent Pages
anything that has to be done further is
just an addition to the already loaded
page so these single page applications
are primarily developed using angular
moving ahead let's look at the features
of angular
we have four features that we're going
to be discussing we have the document
object model type script data binding
and testing now let's look at them one
by one now the document object model
treats an XML or an HTML document as a
tree structure now here every node in
the tree structure defines an object
representing a part of your document
angular uses the regular Dom now let's
suppose you've made 10 updates on a
single HTML page so every time you make
a change the corresponding Dom or the
tree structure needs to be updated
angular
of the entire tree structure of HTML
tags moving on to our next feature
we have typescript
now typescript defines a set of types to
JavaScript which helps you write
JavaScript that is easier to understand
now all the typescript code compiles
down to basic JavaScript that can run
smoothly on any platform now typescript
is not mandatory for developing an
angular application but it is highly
recommended the main reason is highly
recommended is that it offers better
syntactic structure while making the
code base easier to understand and
maintain now typescript can be installed
as an npm package now to do that you
just have to run the command npm install
hyphen G type script on your command
prompt now next up is data binding now
data binding is a process that allows
you to manipulate web page elements
using the web browser now it mainly
employs Dynamic HTML and does not
require complex scripting or programming
it is used in web pages that include
interactive components like calculators
tutorials Games Etc now incremental
display of a web page makes data binding
extremely convenient when Pages contain
a large amount of data when it comes to
angular it uses two-way data binding so
any changes need in the UI element is
reflected in the corresponding model
state
and conversely any changes made in the
model state are reflected onto the UI
State this allows the framework to
connect to Tom to the model data via the
controller the last feature we're
discussing is testing
angular uses Jasmine to run its various
tests the Jasmine framework allows
various functionalities to write
different kinds of test cases karma is a
task Runner to the tests that use a
configuration file to set the startup
reporters and testing framework so with
that we've covered the features of
angular
so let's go ahead and understand
the architecture of angular
angular is a full-fledged MVC framework
it provides a strong opinion on how the
application should be structured and
offers bi-directional data flow and
updates the real Dom MEC short for model
view controller is an architectural
pattern that separates the application
layer into model view and controller the
model here relates to all the data
related logic view on the other hand is
used for UI logic of the application
and controller is the brain of the setup
now it is an interface between the model
and view
moving on let's look at the advantages
of angular
first up we have custom components
angular allows you to build your
build your pack functionality along with
rendering logic into reusable pieces
data binding as discussed angular allows
you to effortlessly move your data from
your JavaScript code to the view and
react to user events without having to
write any code yourself
dependency injection angular allows you
to write modular services and have them
injected wherever they are needed this
greatly improves the testability and
reusability of the same don't worry if
you can't wrap your head around these
topics we're going to discuss them
further in the coming videos
next Advantage is testing angular has
been built from the ground up with
testability in mind you can literally
test every part of your application
comprehensive angular is a full-fledged
framework and provides out-of-the-box
solutions for Server communication
routing and more
lastly we have excellent browser
compatibility angular is cross-platform
and browser compatible an angular
application can typically run on all
browsers with chrome Firefox Safari and
platforms like Windows Mac OS and Linux
now many versions of angular have been
released ever since its Inception all of
these versions have added to their
working of the framework now here are
the different versions released first up
was angular 1. it was built on
JavaScript and completely based on
controllers next release was angular 2.
now this Incorporated the component
based approach wherein the entire UI was
divided into several components and
lastly integrated to give the final
logic next was angular 4 it included
route adaptation of angular CLI or
command line interface 1.0 was
introduced however not deployed in this
release the angular CLI was optimized
and commands like NG update and NG add
were added in the angular 7 release
prompts were introduced which provided
tips in CLI about the functions being
used
in angular 8 IB renderer and bazel were
introduced
and finally the most recent release was
angular 9. now this came with the better
framework and angular material now this
completely switched to the IV renderer
as a default compiler now that we've
learned about the pros of using angular
let's look at some of the limitations of
angular
last up is a steep learning girl now
since angular is a complete full-fledged
framework it becomes difficult for
Learners to begin with you need to be
acquainted with simple topics and then
move on to more advanced topics to
become proficient in this language
next up is limited SEO options now
angular offers limited SEO options and
poor accessibility to search engine
Crawlers
if you were both and complex have a
common issue faced by the angular
Community is the verbosity of the
framework it also poses to be complex
compared to other front-end tools
and lastly migration now one of the
drawbacks of angular is poor migration
now it becomes difficult
Legacy core to angular style
architecture
also with each new release it is painful
to upgrade and a lot of them are not
Backward Compatible
next up let's look at the angular
learning curve
now if you wish to learn angular you
need to be acquainted with basic topics
in angular some of them are directors
modules decorators components Services
dependency injection pipes and templates
now once you've mastered your Basics you
will want to go and understand more
advanced topics such as change detection
zones aot compilation and rx.js however
the learning curve of angular is
clear-cut in the beginning it could be a
little intimidating but once you start
using the tool it becomes way more
easier to comprehend and understand what
is going on
and lastly let's look at some of the
companies that use angular today
many top tier companies like Nike Forbes
Google HBO Sony upwork among others
readily deploy angular so moving on
let's look at the prerequisites for
angular
first up we have node.js angular uses
node.js as its base for a large part of
its build environment
so as a result to get started with
angular you will need to have node.js
installed on your environment so head to
their official website and download the
latest release for your corresponding
operating system next up is the angular
CLI now this command line interface is a
tool that makes it easier to bootstrap
and develop your angular applications
now to install the latest version run
the command npm install hyphen G at
angular front slash CLI you got to run
this command on your command prompt and
finally to confirm installation check
for its version
now the next thing that you will need is
an IDE or a text editor to type your
code now there are several Ides that you
can choose from but in this series we've
used vs code throughout so it is
available on all platforms so go ahead
and download it if you haven't already
now moving on to the final part is the
demo now that you have a basic
understanding of angular and its
prerequisites I think you're ready to
create your first angular application so
let's head to our vs code and begin here
I've created a folder called angular on
my desktop and opened it on my visual
studio code so to create your app you
need to open the terminal just go here
and
select new terminal
and now type in the command Ng
new
and provide the name for your app so I'm
just gonna say hello world
so now this is going to create
just say yes
so basically what happens is that when
you run the command it will
automatically generate a skeleton
application under the folder that is
Hello World in our case and it includes
a bunch of files and installs all the
necessary dependencies for the angular
application
so this could take a while
so once you've created your application
to run it first change the directory so
let's say CD
hello world
and now use the command NG sir
now once it's compiled you need to go to
your browser and type in localhost 4200
and once you do that
you can see your UI
you can see that the application has
been loaded onto your browser and it
says hello world app is running
so this is how you create your
application
so let's go back to our vs code now as
you can see here
there are many files and folders that
are created right so let's look at a few
of them of course we can't explain
everything but I'll brush through a few
of them
so the first main component is basically
the root component now the root
component here is the index.html
so here if you open the file in C
it's a very small crisp code right but
the most important thing in the file is
this app Root element
so what this does is it's basically the
marker for loading your application code
so this is extremely important so the
next important file is the main.ts
now this is the part of the
bootstrapping piece all right so the
index.html file is responsible for
deciding which files are to be loaded
correct the main.ts file on the other
hand identifies which angular module is
to be loaded when the application starts
so this is just a brief explanation as
to what they are doing
next we have the app folder now here we
have the app dot module.ts file now this
application module file can be thought
of as a core configuration of your
application
so here's where the source code starts
from and moving on we have the
app.component.ts these are all
typescript files hence the extension TS
now this file basically is the root
component of your application and then
we have the HTML file for the same which
defines the appearance of what you can
see on your browser so let me just
change the message that is being
displayed
so I'll say hey
welcome to this
angular
tutorial so let's save this and when we
go back to our browser
we can see the message hey welcome to
this angular tutorial being displayed
so like this we can make a simple change
and then it gets rendered onto your
browser so this was just a brief
explanation of what happens in the
background of your application
first we'll get acquainted to what
exactly angular components are then I'll
help you create an angular component by
showing a quick demo and lastly we'll
learn about component decorator metadata
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our Channel if you love
watching new and interesting technology
videos also hit the Bell icon to never
miss an update so what exactly are
angular components
now I'm sure everybody uses web
applications and one of the most widely
used applications is Gmail correct now
to help you understand what components
are consider them as Lego blocks now
they basically are combined together to
form the final application so in this
case here we have the logo component
then you have a sign in component an
image component and then a create
account component now all of these
components generally don't affect the
working of each other but however when
embedded they Define the UI of your
application
so I hope you understood what components
are so to go ahead let's discuss some of
its common features now firstly they are
the building blocks of an application
generally you have a root component
which is basically the app component and
then it branches out into other
components creating a hierarchy
and these components are a subset of
directives now don't worry about what
deductives are because we'll cover them
later on in the series but to give you
an idea there are three types of
directives you have the structural
directives the attribute directives and
the component directives
only one component can be instantiated
per element in a template now components
are typically custom HTML elements and
each of these elements can instantiate
only one component
now don't worry you'll understand this
better when I show you the demo
nextly a typescript class is used to
create a component now this class is
then decorated with the at component
decorator Now The Decorator accepts a
metadata object that gives information
about the component now a component must
belong to the NG module in order for it
to be usable by another component or
application
and finally components control their
runtime Behavior by implementing life
cycle hooks so this was just a brief
introduction to what annular components
are
now you will only be able to understand
the working of components when I show it
to you practically so let's head over to
a Visual Studio code now here back in my
vs code I've created a folder called
angular demo within which I've created
an angular application called demo
components once executed the browser
looks something like this so if you
haven't watched a previous video on
getting started with angular that is
angular hello world I highly suggest you
go through that video first it helps you
create your first angular application so
um now let's go ahead and create our
first component now the command used to
create our component is NG GC and your
component name once executed it creates
four different files now let's just see
how this works on RVs code now what you
can do is head to your terminal and type
in the command Ng
g c
and provide a name for your component
for example I'm gonna just call my
component text component all right
so what it does is that it creates four
different files you can see you have
four different files that have been
created and finally it updates the file
that is app.module.ts indicating that
this new component has been created so
here in your Source folder within which
is an app folder and again here you can
see that your four different files have
been created first is the HTML file
where you can Define all the code that
you want for your component next you
have the CSS file for your styling then
you have the dot TS file which includes
the component decorator and finally you
have spec dot TS which is basically a
unit test file all right and then in
your app.module.ts you can observe that
the company that you've created that is
text component has been imported that is
what the message conveys here all right
now let's go back to our
app.component.html now this basically
has all the corefair applications so let
me just get rid of it
and I'm just gonna display a basic
heading saying
hello
welcome all right so let me save it and
if you go ahead and look at your browser
hello welcome message is displayed now
let's go back to our component dot HTML
file and here let me
provide a message
[Music]
let me say h
three
and let me display a message saying
welcome to this tutorial
on angular components all right now in
your text component dot TS file which is
your typescript file the selector
mentioned here is app hyphen text
component now go ahead and copy this
and in your final
component.html go ahead and create your
custom HTML tag with the selector that
you just copied now this indicates that
the component that you just created that
is a text component is being
Incorporated in the final render so what
happens is that whatever is defined in
the component.html file is also being
rendered in your final output so when I
save this let's go ahead and check
our browser you can see that the message
welcome to this tutorial on angular
components is displayed so this was a
simple creation of a component now for
this let's give it some styling so here
go to your dot CSS file and provide some
styling see for example here I just say
text line
and let me say Center and also in my
app.companying.cs I'm going to give the
same thing and see each one
text align is Center
all right so let me save this
and there we go
now we can also create multiple
components and Define the tags in the
app component now the components are
executed sequentially so now let's
create another component just to give
you a brief insight into it let's say NG
GC image component
now here I'm going to be adding the
simply learn logo so I'll show you how
that works
now you can see that a new component has
been created with four files again so in
my assets folder here I've added the
logo so what I can do is back in my HTML
file I can go ahead and create an image
tag so first let me just display another
message here
just to avoid any confusion and let me
say this is the image component
[Music]
and then let me say
image
Source equals so the source is basically
assets
[Music]
slash logo dot PNG
and class
equals
Center
[Music]
all right so you can also head to your
CSS file and provide any sort of styling
that you need so let me just say
text
align
to be Center
and then let's create
a styling for the image
and here I mentioned the code for the
image so let's save this and from the
dot CS file let's copy the selector
and create a custom HTML tag in our
final component.html file
[Music]
so there we go let's save this and check
the output
and there we go first the hello welcome
message is displayed next you have the
message displayed from the first
component and then you have the second
component so this is how you can create
your own components and don't forget to
incorporate these selectors into your
final HTML file
so moving on to our next topic component
decorator metadata now as mentioned
earlier the at component decorator
accepts a metadata object that provides
information about the component correct
here is a list of properties of the
metadata object first up is the selector
now basically the selector is a CSS
selector that identifies this particular
component in a template now this
corresponds to the HTML tag that is
included in the parent component you can
create your own HTML tag however the
same has to be included in the parent
component so to help you understand that
better let's head back to our vs code
and say for example in our text
component
here
the selector says text component correct
for the time being let's change it to
say n component
all right now when you save it and look
at the browser the message is not
displayed
so what we can do is you can copy this
selector and then include this
here
and now you can see that the same
component has been rendered onto your
output
all right so the selector plays a
crucial role in that
next up we have the template now a
template is an inline defined template
for the view now the template can be
used to provide some particular markup
the markup could typically include some
headings or paragraphs that are
displayed on the UI
next up we have template URL now it is
the URL for the external file containing
the template for The View
so here you can see
this is basically the external file that
contains the template for the view next
up you have Styles now these are also
inline defined styles that can be
applied to the components view so any
code that you provide in the dot CSS
file can also be included here next you
have the style URLs now this is a list
of URLs to your style sheets that are
applied on your components View
next up you have providers now this is
again an array where certain Services
can be registered for your component
lastly we have animations as the name
suggests these are animations that can
be listed for your components
first we'll understand what exactly
dependency injection is
then we'll understand the demerit or the
drawback of not using dependency
injection
then we'll understand dependency
injection as a design pattern and
finally I'll help you understand the
entire concept with the help of a demo
so let's begin
what exactly is dependency injection so
let's consider this I'm sure you're
aware that angular uses the concept of
components the entire UI of the
application is divided into several
components now what have all of these
components perform similar tasks be it
accessing the database rendering images
Etc now instead of writing the same
piece of code for every component you
could write the code once and then
perhaps inject the same code into every
component now this is supported by
dependency injection
now to give you a better example
consider two classes A and B now let's
assume that a uses the objects of Class
B and normally in object oriented
programming an instance of Class B is
created so that a can access its objects
with using dependency injection we move
the creation and binding of dependent
objects outside of the class that depend
on them so dependency injection or di
keeps the code more flexible testable
and mutable also classes can inherit
external logic without having to create
on its own and lastly di benefits
directives pipes and components
next up let's have a look at the
drawback of not using dependency
injection
now let's consider Class Postal details
that is dependent on the number and the
address class
in the postal details class the
Constructor creates copies of the number
and address
so when you instantiate a new postal
details class the Constructor
instantiates a unique number and address
now although this looks simple there's a
problem with this code let's assume that
the number and address class
Constructors now accept parameters when
we change the numbers class the postal
details class gets broken now to
overcome this what we need to do is we
need to pass parameter to the number
Constructor so this applies to address
as well the first drawback of using this
traditional method is that the code is
not very flexible anytime the
dependencies change the postal details
class needs to be changed as well
and the second drawback is that the code
is not suitable for testing
once you instantiate the new postal
details class you get the same number
and address even if you change the
number and address classes every time
what if these classes are in turn
dependent on other classes
then it's going to be a chain reaction
so to overcome this we make use of
dependency injection
now let's look at di as a pattern
dependency injection as you all know is
a coding pattern where a class receives
its dependence he's from an external
Source rather than creating them on its
own so here in the above example we have
moved the definition of dependencies
from inside the Constructor to the
constructor's parameters
so the postal details class doesn't
create the dependencies anymore
it just consumes them so the postal
dependencies class doesn't create the
dependencies anymore
so with that we overcome the drawbacks
of not using Di
so now that you know what exactly
dependency injection is and how vital it
is let's look at a simple demonstration
to understand the concept better now
services classes modules components all
of these are benefactors of dependency
injection so in the demo I'm going to be
showing how dependency injection can be
used with the help of services and
injecting these Services into classes so
the main thought behind this is normally
components are used to ensure just a
good user experience these components do
not generally execute tasks so to
execute these tasks we make use of
services so a component can delegate
tasks like fetching data from the server
any network related issues
ETC to a particular service and these
Services can be made available to
components now with the same thought
what I'm going to be doing is I'll be
creating a service that performs the
task of displaying an employee list
later we're going to inject the service
into the class using dependency
injection
so let's head to our Visual Studio code
for the demonstration
all right so as discussed I'll have to
first create a component that displays a
button for the employee and then I have
to create a service class and inject it
into my component now this service holds
the employee details such as name
employee ID email ID
Etc so first let's go ahead and create a
component
so here let me just type
n g g c
and the name of the component I'm
providing is M info
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
so as you
use your component with four different
files all right so the next thing we
have to do is we have to create a
service so to create that we make use of
the command n g g s
you can either give s or service and the
service name I'm providing is records so
let me just say records here
all right here you can see two files are
created there is a spect.ts file and the
dot TS file all right so now the service
contains all the employee data that
needs to be displayed right so let's go
ahead and write the data so first we're
going to make use of three arrays I'm
going to be displaying employee records
for three employees so I'll have to
create three arrays and provide certain
information so let's go ahead and do
that
all right so the area I'm creating is
called info one for the first employee
and I'm going to be passing
information like name employee ID and
the email ID so the arrays of type
string
and within which let me just mention the
details I'm giving random information
I'm just saying Adam Taylor
and some random
employee ID
and let's say 80 at abc.net
all right so I'm going to be creating
three records so I'll just copy the same
thing and paste with the rest too
let's just change here
provide a different name here
and same for the last one
and let me change the name of the array
as well
followed so with the agenda to retrieve
this data in our component we make use
of the method for the same right so this
method Returns the employee data
so let's go ahead and create this method
I'm going to call it get info
and then just say string
and then this will just return
this dot info one
all right I'm going to be calling it get
info one for better understanding
same for the rest two as well
I'm just gonna return different arrays
here
now that and lastly info three all right
now in order to retrieve this
information in our component we need
three more arrays right three more
arrays I will receive this data let's go
back to our component dot TS file here
and then type in the following code
so I've created three arrays again uh
info received one two and three
now what we need to do is we have to
accept the information that is being
sent from the service correct now as I
mentioned services are implemented with
the help of dependency injection so what
we need to do is we'll have to first
import the service into the component.ts
file
the key reason behind doing this is that
when angular creates this component and
instance of the service class is also
made to perform the necessary tasks
correct so let's go ahead and just
import it here
so I'll say import
[Music]
records
services
I'm sorry service
from
and let's say records.service
all right and what we have to do next is
that we must also declare this instance
that is being created in the provider's
area of the component
all right so
let's just say providers
and then say records
service
all right now we've created the instance
of this class right however to access
this instance an object is also created
so this object will in turn access the
methods and variables of the service
class
so for that we have to create another
object so let's do that here in our
Constructor method let's say Constructor
private
foreign
is called our service you can give a
name of your choice and then I'm gonna
just say records service
all right now this object will help me
retrieve data from the service so let's
go ahead and use this in order to get
the employee details all right so I've
created three different methods here get
info from service class 2 1 and 3 and
these methods will retrieve the data and
add it to our array here that is info
received all right and lastly we'll have
to create an unordered list in our HTML
file here we haven't added anything so
let me get rid of this
so now I have to create three different
buttons for three different employees
and when the user clicks on the button
the data is retrieved from the service
and then displayed on the UI right
so as you can see I've created buttons
for three different employees
and then I've made use of a bootstrap
class called list group info and then
I've
interpolated info which displays the
contents
of the info variable all right now in
order to call the methods in the dot TS
file we have to bind them with the
button so since it is bound with the
click event every time you click on the
button the information is displayed
so now the last thing we have to do is
we'll have to create a custom HTML tab
for the component and then add it to the
main component
so let's just do that let me copy this
here
and then in my app component.html let me
get rid of this
and then let me just create this I've
just created the custom HTML tag for my
component
and now just to beautify the code I'll
write a heading
and let's say employee
foreign
logo
say image source
[Music]
I've I've added the image here so let me
just say logo dot PNG
I've also added some styling to it all
right so now let me just save this and
have a look at the browser
so here we go we have the logo here and
then employee details heading and then
we have three different buttons created
that is employee one two and three and
when I click on it
the information of the employee is
displayed the name the ID and their
email address
so yeah so this is how you can make use
of dependency injection and inject a
service class into a component
dependency injection plays a crucial
role in angular
will understand what angular forms are
then we'll look at the different types
of form buildings supported by angular
next up we'll get acquainted with
features like form control and group
control
and we learn all of this with the help
of a simple demo
so without further Ado let's begin
so what exactly are angular forms
now I'm sure every application that you
use comes with certain amount of form
filling correct be it your login
credentials or your sign up forms or any
sort of registration forms Etc so forms
are an integral part of a web
application you need forms to update
your profile or to enter sensitive
information or also to perform any sort
of data related tasks so now let's look
at the different types of form building
supported by angular
first up angular supports two types of
form building
first you have the template driven
approach and second you have the
reactive approach
now let's look at them one by one
so talking about template driven
approach in this method the conventional
form tag is used to create forms so
angular automatically interprets and
creates a form object with the help of
the directors
Now controls can be added to the form
using the mg model tag now multiple
controls can be grouped using the NG
control group module so it basically
uses several module classes to provide
controls now if you don't get this don't
worry you'll understand better when I'm
showing you the demo
next up is Json values so form value can
be generated using the form.value object
form data is exported as Json values
when the submit method is called
lastly basic HTML validations can be
used to validate the form fields in the
case of custom validations directives
can be used so arguably this method is
the simplest way to create an angular
form
so moving on to the active approach now
this approach is the programming
Paradigm revolving around data flows and
propagation of change
now with reactor forms the component
directly manages the data flows between
the form controls and the data models
now reactive forms are code driven
unlike template driven approach
reactive forms eliminate the
anti-pattern of updating the data model
via two-way data binding so it does not
use two-way data binding
and typically a reactive form control
creation is synchronous and can be unit
tested with synchronous programming
techniques
so now let's go ahead and look at form
control and form group
so consider a typical form consisting of
fields like name age and location
now a form control is basically a class
that enables validation of these fields
for each input field an instance of this
class is created now these instances
help check the values of the field and
see if they're either touched untouched
dirty pristine valid invalid and so on
so this allows you to check every field
for the value it makes it easier to
understand which Fields value is invalid
or which field has not been entered
Etc
now moving on to form group
so a form group class represents a group
of controls a form can have multiple
group controls the form group returns
true if all the controls are valid and
provides validation errors if there are
any so I hope this was clear
so moving ahead let's look at the demo
to explain all of these features I'm
sure it will become extremely clear once
you look at the demo so for that let's
head to our vs code
so back in my vs code
I've created a component called form
component and I've also included the
simply learn logo just to purify the
appearance so once you execute the code
this is what you're gonna see on your
browser so you just have the logo at the
moment
the first thing we need to do is we'll
have to import the forms module all
right so oh uh but before we begin let
me tell you what the use case is so
we're going to be creating a user
registration form which is going to
include four fields that is the first
name last name email ID and the password
all right so now let me show you how to
import the forms module so in your main
app.module.ts file you'll have to import
forms module from angular forms
all right and then in your Imports
you'll have to just call it here
all right so this is just a simple step
and now once you're done with that let's
go ahead and start our form creation
so here in my component.html let's
enclose the entire form within a div tag
so here let me see div
class
is a container
foreign
within which let me just have one
heading
which says user registration
all right and now let's go ahead and
create our form
so first let me just say form
now I'm going to create a div class for
every field so say div
class
equals form group
I'll explain it to you a little later
now first let's create a label
so label tag
for
basically it's the first name
so let me just say first name
and the tab will basically have
first name again
all right and let me just break the line
next we have the field so let's say
input
type is text
name is
first name
and we have a class which is
the form control class
all right
so this will have to do for all the
other fields so let me just copy this
paste it like four times
I'll also add the tag three for spacing
let's do that here
and finally we'll have the button
so let's just add that here
with a type subnet
and let's just say submit on the button
so now let's go ahead and change these
values here
so here let me just change it to last
name
here as well
and here as well
and in this case it is going to be email
so let me just change it here
and finally we have passwords so
let's add that here
all right so let's save this and just
have a look at our browser
so there we go we have our uh user
registration form ready but I would like
to uh align it to the center so let me
just do that
so here in my CSS file I'm just going to
uh align all the div tags in the center
and the label tag to the left so let me
save this and look at the browser now
and there we go we have our registration
form with a logo so this is how you
create a simple form
now we'll have to add a directive called
NG model now this directive when added
into the input tag will provide form
controls to every input field all right
so here let's just go ahead and say NG
model
that is it
so let me just copy this and paste it
for every other field
all right let me save this and back in
my browser let me inspect
and here you can see different types of
classes like NG untouched NG pristine NG
ballot are added
right so this indicates that angular has
recognized the form Tab and it has added
these classes to the form as well as all
the fields
so this is achieved when you add the NG
model directive in your input tag now
back in my vs code now every form has an
output property attached to it called NG
submit all right so this property can be
bound within a method that method called
the submit method
so once submitted this method is called
right so once we click on the submit
button this method has to be called so
to include that
we'll have to just save
form
and G submit
equals
submit
[Music]
all right so now we have to define the
submit method
in our component.ts file so here let me
just go to our component.ts file and let
me
just get rid of unnecessary code here
and let's define a function
or submit
and then here let me just
console law
form submitted
all right so let me just get rid of this
as well it's unnecessary here
let's save this so what it means is that
every time you click on the submit
button
this method is called all right so let's
just have a look at the browser so first
let's go to our console
and when I click on submit it says form
submitted
all right so the next crucial step is to
generate JavaScript representation now
we'll have to make use of another
directive called NG form that is
assigned to a template variable
okay so this JavaScript representation
helps with validating all the fields so
I'll help you understand that better
so back in our HTML file
let's just create a variable first
let's call it login
all right and say Ng
form
okay now the mg form object includes the
JavaScript representation so now while
you're calling the submit method you're
going to pass login as a parameter
so let's just say login here
and in my ts file again let's just say
login
and along with it
I want login to be displayed so
I say login again
so now let's save this and if you have a
look at the browser let's click on
submit
and now here you can see the JavaScript
representation So within form
I can
check for email
or say first name and here for this
field first name you can see different
properties attached you can see invalid
is it invalid or is it untouched
which is true or are there any errors so
this basically gives you all information
about the particular field
so we can make use of this feature to
validate the information so we're going
to learn about that in our next segment
moving on to form validation one way to
ensure that incorrect fields are not
submitted is by disabling the submit
button
correct now apart from this you can also
specify certain properties in your input
tag for the corresponding input field
now um let's say that the fields that
now let's say that the fields can't be
empty and the form only accepts names
with the minimum length of 2 and the
maximum length of seven all right so
here in my input tag I just mentioned a
required meaning this field cannot be
empty
and Min length
2 2
and
max length
to say seven
all right
so to check this
let's go to our browser
and here
let me submit the form without filling
the first name
and evidently there has to be an error
so when I submit it
and I look here
what's in forms and here controls
and my first name you can see that an
error is shown here it says required
equals true that means that there is one
error now you can make use of these form
control objects you can leverage form
control objects to ensure field
validation and display a message
whenever an error occurs
right so to do that you need to access
these objects like errors or invalid or
touched all of these properties or
objects need to be
accessed for that we'll have to create a
template variable
and then this variable is assigned to
this object
so back in our vs code
let's create
a variable let me call it
name
and let's say NG model
all right here the readable name
receives the control object
so here back in my browser when I submit
again without the first name
you can see that the invalid
property is set to True correct so this
helps us use this property to alert the
user with the help of a simple if logic
so back in my
vs code let me create
another div tag
within which I mentioned NG if
foreign
[Music]
name which is our template variable name
dot touched
and name dot invalid
is true
right then I'm going to alert
so I'm gonna
make use of an alert here let's say
alert
Danger
all right so in my CSS file I'll have to
mention the simple styling for alert
so here let me just say
so we're gonna have the background color
red for danger right and here I'm going
to display the message
invalid in bold
foreign
so now let's go back to our browser and
check it
so let me proceed without entering the
last name it says invalid here
so this was a simple demonstration to
show you form validation
of course you can modify the code
depending on your requirement say
suppose the length of the first name is
too short then you can alert the user
with a different message or uh suppose
they have missed out on filling a form
field then you can again alert the user
so you can basically make use of the
nested if condition right now just to
help you understand that better let me
just show it to you
now back in my HTML file
instead of invalid let me have another
tag a paragraph tag
because in which I make use of NG if
again
now ngf
name dot errors
[Music]
dot required
is true
then I display the message first
name required
all right
and if
the length of the first name is
not 2.
now if the length of the first name is
less than 2 then I'm going to display
another message so let me just say
name dot errors
dot Min length
if this is true then I'm going to say
sorry
short first name
all right so let's save this and have a
look at the browser
when I proceed without providing the
name it says first name required but
when I type in one character it says
sorry short first name but if I type in
another character it accepts so I hope
this made you understand how form
validation works
so this was just a simple demonstration
again now I highly recommend you explore
these properties and play around with
these objects uh trust me it's really
fun so I hope this tutorial helped you
out I'm sure you all know that an
angular app is divided into several
components for example you have the logo
component you have the sign in component
and image component and say a create
account component
now these components are Standalone and
each of them represents a part of the
user interface
now imagine if all of these components
performed common tasks for example
access in the database or rendering
images on The View
tasks like those now instead of having
to write the code for every component
you can just make use of angular
services
now the service can be written once and
then injected into all of these
components
now a service could be a function it
could be a variable or a feature that an
application needs
so the main use of a service is to write
code once and avoid rewriting of it now
the same code can be injected into
several components that make use of this
particular service
but what are angular services
so normally components are used to
ensure a good user experience now that
is the extent of it components make sure
that whatever is being rendered onto the
screen is right and pristine
but in order to execute tasks we make
use of services and this approach is
ideal
so a component can basically delegate
tasks like fetching data from the server
validating user input or logging
directly to the console to a particular
service
and these tasks can be made available to
any component in the app
so let's talk about a few features of
angular services
now typically an angular service is
simply a typescript class with an at
injectable decorator
this decorator tells Angela that the
class is a service and can be injected
into components that need that service
now they can be used to share the same
piece of code they can also inject other
services as dependencies
now these Services hold valuable
business logic
and can also be used to interact with
the back end now for example if you want
to make Ajax calls you can have methods
to those calls in a service and then use
it as a dependency in files
and as mentioned earlier it can be used
to share data among several components
in angular services are Singleton
meaning that only a single instance of a
service gets created and the same
instance is used by each and every
building block in the application and
finally a service can be registered as a
part of a module or it can be registered
as a part of the component now to
register it as a part of the component
you'll have to specify it in the
provider's array of the module
I'm sure you'll understand the concept
of services better if we look at a
simple demo so in the next section we're
going to look at a demo but before that
let me tell you the use case
so basically in the demo what we'll do
is we'll create an employee details list
say for example you will have employee
information like name employee ID and
their email ID we'll create a database
of say three employees
and on the browser when you click on the
employee button it displays the
information about that particular
employee
and at the end we can also add
information to the employees details so
without delay let's head to our vs code
and start learning angular Services
Hands-On so here first I've created a
folder called demo underscore angular
which in which I've created a file
called hello world so uh this was
previously used for a tutorial so the
name is just hello world so don't get
confused
however when you look at the browser
I've written an initial code here which
is angular services and I have the
simply learn logo
so back in my browser this is what the
UI looks like
so uh to
understand the concept of angular
Services first let's go ahead and create
a component
so here I'm going to say NG g c
e info
I'm creating a component for employee
information
so as you can see
inside my app file we have the e-info
component which has these four files so
if you're wondering what exactly
components are and how this is working
then I highly suggest you watch our
components video first
so now let's go ahead and create a
service
so I'm just typing in the command n g g
service here G stands for Generate and
we're generating a service and the name
of the service that I'm providing is
data
so now it creates a service
which is going to be a DOT TS file
so you can observe that dot service is
appended this indicates that it is a
service all right
as mentioned earlier we have to display
the employee details correct so for that
in my component.ts file I'm going to
create an array that displays the
employee information in our case I'm
creating a three different employee
records so for that I'll have three
different arrays so let me just call the
arrays info
receipt
one indicating this is the information
of first employee and this is going to
be of type string
and I'll just initialize it to null
for now
all right and I'm going to create
two other
arrays
and let me just
change
the name of that is all right
so now uh to retrieve the information
I'll have to create a method again I'm
creating three methods for uh the three
different employee records
so I'm gonna call the array get info
from service one indicating it's again
for employee one
and
I'm just gonna leave it as it is for now
I'll tell you how the information is
being received
and I'm gonna do the same for the other
two uh employee records so let me just
copy paste and here I'm just going to
change
the name of the methods
all right so uh this is the initial code
for retrieving information however we'll
have to create the employee record in
our service
so back here in my data.ts file
what I'm gonna do is
I'll create three different uh Records
for the employees so let me say info one
which is going to be of type string
all right
and let me just give a random names say
for example I say John
Matthew
[Music]
all right
and employee ID say
if 354
and let me just give a random
email ID and say JM at abc.net
all right so I'm gonna do the same for
the other two uh Records
so let me just create another one and
call it info 2.
and the name I'm providing is say Rob
listen
with a different employee ID says 673
and I'm just gonna make it RW at abc.net
and another record for employee number
three
and I'm just gonna say Rose Adams
[Music]
with
some employee ID
and an email ID all right
so now we've created the employee
records so what I have to do is I have
to create a method that returns these
employee records
correct so for that I'm just gonna
create another method called get info
one
which is of type string
and it just returns
this dot info one
all right similarly for the rest of the
two records I'm just gonna retrieve them
let's say in four two and get info two
and again
I'm just gonna make it get in for three
and this is gonna return
in four three
all right so I'm sure you've got an idea
as to what I'm doing here so basically
this information is going to be
retrieved in our employee component
correct so for that I'll have to make
use of dependency injection
so here I'll have to import the service
that I've created so let's go ahead and
say import
[Music]
the service with data service
all right
from
[Music]
slash data.service all right
now the main reason we're doing this is
to tell angular that when the component
is created the service instance is also
created and this instance is being used
to perform particular tasks and for that
we'll also have to include this in our
provider's array so here let me just say
providers
[Music]
and let's say data service
now to access this instance of service
that is created we make use of a
property
so uh this property basically allows us
to access all the methods that are
defined in the service class
all right so here in my Constructor
method I'm just gonna say
private
and you can give any name for your
property and here I'm just giving the
name d service
all right and which is of type
data service
all right
so now with the help of this property I
can retrieve information from the
service class so here I'm just going to
say
this Dot
info receipt
equals this dot d service
dot get info one
all right so what it basically does is
that it calls the get info one method in
our service which Returns the
information of the first employee
and this information is being stored in
the array that is info received one
so similarly for the next two methods
I'm just gonna use the same piece of
code
let me just change it here
all right
and
same for the third one
all right
so now that we have the logic behind
what is being displayed
let's go ahead and create the UI for it
here in my HTML file
I'm going to create
an unordered list
[Music]
and now I'm gonna make use of
the NG
for director
to basically Loop over the record and
display everything so for that I have to
make use of a particular variable so
I'll just say
let info
of info receipt
so
um you can check here in our TS file
though
array is info received correct so I'm
going to make use of the same array here
and since it's displaying the first
employee record I'm just going to
say
info received one
all right and let me just create a a
Class A bootstrap class of list
group
item of list group info
and we're just gonna have to interpolate
info
all right that is basically going to
display what the information holds what
the info variable holds
all right and here as well let me create
a bootstrap class
called list
group
all right I hope this was clear to you
so basically here the information is
being retrieved with the help of this
method right let us get info from
service one so in order to call this
method we'll have to bind it with a
button all right so that's what we're
going to do let's just
copy this and here I'm going to create a
button
foreign
and the type
this button
[Music]
with name
button again
all right so I'm going to bind it with
the click event
so what happens is that when I click on
it this particular method gets called
all right I'm just pasting the method
here
and finally let's just provide the name
employee one
for the button all right
so similarly we'll have to do the same
for the other two records as well
letter all right so uh what I'm going to
do is I'm just gonna paste the same
twice
and here I'm gonna just change the names
I'll say 2 here and this is again for
employee two
and I'm going to change this as well
it's going to be employed I'm sorry it's
going to be in four received two this is
going to be in for receipt 3.
and finally employee 3.
all right uh and lastly we'll have to
include
the selector that is app hyphen e info
in our main component dot HTML so here
let me just
create a custom tag alright and save
this so now let's go back to our browser
and see what it looks like
so here you can see that uh three
different buttons have been created for
employee one two and three and when you
click on it it retrieves information
that is the name the employee ID and
their email IDs so we've successfully
created an angular service and injected
it into our component to retrieve
information all right so now the last
part of the use case that we discussed
was uh to add another detail that is the
employee detail in the record all right
so for that we'll have to take uh input
from the user and in our case we're
taking the location now we're also
adding the same location for all three
employees so this is what services do
you know they can be used to update
modify alter anything that happens in
the back end so you can tweak the code a
little bit and you can change the entire
uh view of your application you can add
information you can delete you can
retrieve you can alter
Etc all right so for that what we're
going to do is back in the HTML file
we'll create a form that basically takes
the input
so I'm just going to say um
[Music]
form
all right within which I'm going to be
defining a div class
[Music]
within which I'm going to be defining a
div tag
inside which I'll have the input tag
of type
text
and uh the name I'm going to be
providing it will be location
all right
[Music]
and we'll have a value and I'll just
leave it blank and finally I'll have NG
model so if you're confused as to what
I'm doing here then I suggest you watch
the angular forms uh video it basically
teaches you uh how to work around with
angular forms
all right and now after this we're gonna
have a button
so let me say button
[Music]
all right
and I'm gonna just say add info
okay
all right so now when I'm creating the
form I'll also have to create a template
variable to access all the values within
my form so if I have to access the
location then I need a variable to
access it so here let me just go ahead
and create a template variable let me
call it frm
and I'm going to make use of the NG form
directive
so this tells angular
that this variable can be used to access
all the values within the form
and since I'm using form here I'll have
to import it in my module file
foreign
and say
import forms module from angular forms
and here in my imports
I'll just say forms module
okay so I've imported the forms module
so now uh back in my HTML file
what I'm going to do is that I'll have
to make use of this template variable
to update my information correct so I'll
have to create another method that will
update information into the records
so here in my component.ts file I'll
have to create another method and I'm
going to call this method update info
method
all right and this basically takes in
the template variable that is form
and let me just specify any
okay and what this is going to do is
that it updates
the record correct so I'm gonna say this
Dot
D service
add info now you must be wondering what
ad info is
I'll just let you know in a minute and
and the value that I'm going to be
passing will be the value that you've
provided as an input which is nothing
but form dot value dot location
all right so now what happens is that
I'll have to again specify what add info
is and this method is going to be
defined in the service file correct
so here I'm going to create another
method that's add info
and I'm going to pass info as a
parameter
and what this method does is that it
just pushes the information or the data
into the arrays
so since I'm going to be pushing the
same information into all of these
arrays that is info 1 info 2 and info 3.
I'm just gonna say this dot info one dot
push
of info
all right and the same for
the other two areas as well
let me just
change these all right
so what exactly I'm doing is that I have
I have a method called add info which
gets information from the component
all right and it basically pushes this
information into the array and also I
have to return it so I'll save return
this dot info
one
all right and I'll save it
and here we have another method called
update info which basically calls uh the
ad info method in our service
and passes the value to it
and in my HTML file also note that the
button type here is submit
and not button so what happens is that
now the value that we've received as an
input has to be passed on to the method
that is update info so here I'll say NG
submit
foreign
update info
and I'm gonna pass
frm as the argument
and now let's save this
and execute
so all right here you can see that we
have an input field and a button saying
add info
so now I can just go ahead and say type
USA
and when I say add info and when I check
on my employee one details USA has been
added to the list
and same goes with employee 2 and
employee 3.
so I hope this simple demo on angular
Services helped you understand the
concept better I highly recommend you
play around and explore other
possibilities
let's understand what exactly is
bootstrap
bootstrap is a powerful toolkit
basically a collection of HTML CSS and
JavaScript tools for creating and
building responsive web applications and
Pages it is a free and open source
project based on GitHub and originally
created by Twitter
now to put it more easily bootstrap is a
giant collection of Handy reusable bits
of code written in HTML CSS and
JavaScript it's also a front-end
development framework that enables
developers and beginners to design quick
and responsive websites
now there are several advantages to
using bootstrap
to name a few bootstrap comes with a
responsive grid you don't have to spend
time working on your layouts
bootstrap comes with its own code for
automatically resizing images based on
the current screen size
it also comes with different components
that you can use for your web page these
components could be navigation bars drop
downs progress bars thumbnails
Etc
it also offers excellent documentation
and is customizable
so bootstrap comes in extremely handy to
create responsive user interface
so now before using bootstrap it needs
to be embedded into your application so
let's see how to embed bootstrap into
angular
now there are two ways to do it first up
is by using the bootstrap CDN or the
content delivery Network
now this enables users to load CSS
JavaScript and images remotely from its
servers
the other method is to use bootstrap npm
bootstrap jQuery and other packages and
Frameworks can be installed via the
command prompt
in the tutorial that I am going to be
showing you I have embedded bootstrap
using npm alright so I'm sure you only
understand the concept better when you
look at a demo
so let's go ahead and create an
application with the help of angular
bootstrap so in this tutorial what I'm
going to be showing is the creation of a
blog post so so let me show you what
we're going to be doing
so here I've created a simple blog
for simply learn and I've added the
simply learn logo I've also written a
few lines about simply learn and what
they offer I've also mentioned their
tagline and when you scroll down you can
see that I've mentioned the different
courses they're offering
and when you click on the more info
button
it navigates to the official page that
gives you the overview for that
particular course so this is for lean
sex Sigma the same for full stack web
development
as well
and uh the same for the last one that is
cyber security
and finally I've added a simple video
here to just make it more uh beautiful
so I've added a simple video
and lastly I've also linked our YouTube
channel so when you click on the YouTube
icon it will navigate to the YouTube
channel
to our YouTube channel here
all right so this is what we're going to
be creating uh using angular bootstrap
so I'm hoping you're all ready for it so
without further delay let's jump in so
first let's find the template that we
want to use for our blog
so for that I'm going to just go ahead
and say
bootstrap
blog template
and I'm just going to click on the first
link that I get
and here
you can choose the template that you
like so I'm just going to look for more
templates here
and the one that we are going to choose
is
oh yeah this one so which is small
businesses so you can go ahead and click
on that you can then click on live
preview
and once you do that
you can just
say view frame source
so here you can see that the HTML code
is available
it has the head section and then the
body section
so the head section consists of a lot of
meta tags and then you have the title
and then you also have the CSS file
references
and then if you look at the body tag you
have different code for different parts
of the UI there's code for navigation
bar and then you have page content code
heading row
call to action and all of that and
lastly you have the footer
so what we're going to be doing is that
we'll take all of the code and then
we'll have to create components for each
of it and then we'll include all the
components in our main
HTML file
so that is the best practice that
angular uses so we're going to make use
of components
and you can also see that when you
scroll down you can see that it has
certain dependencies so here it has the
bootstrap dependency and then you have
jQuery so we'll have to download them
so we'll have to install them and as
mentioned earlier we're going to be
installing them with the help of npm
so for that we'll have to head back to
our vs code here
back in my vs code I've created a
folder called angular demo and then I've
also created a file called demo
components
and here
I'm just going to say CD
demo components
within which I'll say npm install
G query
[Music]
so this could take a while and once
you've installed jQuery go ahead and
type npm install bootstrap
[Music]
all right so we've successfully
installed jQuery and bootstrap so now we
need to add the references to these
JavaScript files to do that go to your
angular.json file
and here we'll have to add them in our
build section so here you can see we
have styles and scripts so in our
scripts array we Define the relative
path to these JavaScript files so these
files are generally uh stored in your
node modules so go ahead and
here you can look for bootstrap
here you go and then in your dist file
and then click on Js
and then you can see you have
bootstrap.min.js
oh well I'm sorry we need
bootstrap.bundle.min.js so here
you can just right click and say copy
relative path
and back in my Json file in my scripts
I'm gonna just paste it here
and make sure to uh
make it a path while providing by
providing forward slash
[Music]
all right and then the next thing we
need is the
jquery.min.js files so for that
again in our node modules you will have
to look for jQuery so here there's
jQuery and then click on test
and then we have jquery.min.js
so again let me just
copy the path
and paste it here
[Music]
follow the same procedure for this as
well
[Music]
all right so we've embedded both our
files in our
angular.json file
so now in our code here in the beginning
they've also included the CSS file so
we'll have to embed that as well so
here back in bootstrap
let me just add the CSS file as well
that's
bootstrap.nint.css I'm just going to
copy the relative path and just provide
it here
[Music]
let me just change these to forward
slash
[Music]
okay so we have our custom style sheet
so what I'm going to do is
I'm just going to copy this
and just paste it in our
[Music]
and then you can just paste it here
all right
so I think we've added all the
dependencies and the custom style sheet
and everything so now let me just close
all of these files
what we can do now is that we can go
ahead and take the code from The Source
here so I'm just going to copy the body
tag
all right
so
I'm gonna copy this till the footer
and then I'm just going to paste it in
my
component.html file
[Music]
so as mentioned earlier I will create
components and then place the code for
specific parts of the UI in these
components
so let me just see if I've got
everything here
okay
so I'll be creating four components the
first one will be for the navigation bar
the second will be for the introduction
and then the third one will be uh to
display the courses that we're providing
and then lastly we'll have the footer
component
right so first let's create these
components I've also created a
components folder here in my app folder
so I just have to
tap in the command
NG g c first we'll create the component
for the top navigation bar so I'm just
saying NG GC so I'm just going to say
components
[Music]
slash nav bar
all right so uh the component has been
created so what I'm going to do is I'll
just
copy this
[Music]
here
all right and the next component I'm
going to be creating is for the
introduction right so I'll say NG g c
[Music]
components slash intro
all right so
so I will have to take
foreign
this code here I'm also going to be
including the call to action part
so I'll just
copy paste this one in my
intro.html file
[Music]
so let me do that and then I'm going to
have the main course content
component so for that I'll say NG GC
components slash courses
[Music]
right
and we're gonna copy the next part of
the code
[Music]
all right until uh till the footer
let me just add it here
and finally we're gonna create the
component for the footer so I'll say NG
GC
components slash
photo
foreign
I'm just going to add it there
[Music]
all right
so now we'll have to create the custom
HTML tags for these components and then
place it in our HTML file right so first
one that we created was the navigation
bar so here
head over to the TS file
just copy the selector
[Music]
and then your
and then in our app.component let me
just
create the tags
similarly for intro
[Music]
it's going to copy the selector
and then for courses so
and add a hyphen courses
that as well
and then lastly we have the footer
component so let me just copy that
paste it here
all right so we've included all the
components so let's just run this
application and see if everything uh is
displayed in that so here let me just
say NG serve so when you execute the
command you can see that the template is
being displayed so you have the
navigation bar you have the
intro component and then we have the
courses component and finally we have
the footer component right okay so now
that we have the template ready we can
go ahead and customize it according to
our needs so now I'm going to be making
a few changes to the code we're going to
add the simply learn logo we're going to
change the tagline here we're going to
display something else over here all
right so let's go back to our vs code to
customize
and display the final output
so here
the first thing that I'm going to be
doing is
changing the message here I'm gonna
display simply learn for that
in our nav bar component
let's go to the HTML code
and here instead of start bootstrap let
me just type in simply learn
[Music]
all right so when you save it and when
you look at the browser
you can see that
simply learn is displayed
and the next thing that I want to do is
I want to add the image right a simply
learn logo
so what I've done here is I've already
added the logo uh dot PNG file in my
assets folder
so I'll just go ahead and provide the
path to this so that's going to be in
our intro files so here
image source is going to be
[Music]
assets
slash
[Music]
logo dot PNG
so let me save this
so there we go the logo is displayed
so the next thing is we'll have to
change this part of the UI so the
information that I want to display is
this
uh I'm gonna be displaying
world's number one online boot camp and
other information so what I'm gonna do
is back in my vs code I'm just gonna
delete
this
and instead of that I'm just gonna
copy this that's world's number one
online boot camp
and then within the paragraph tag I'll
display something else so let me get rid
of this
[Music]
let me just copy the information that I
want to display
paste it here
[Music]
and let me just give a line break
let me save this and see if it's
displayed
so yeah we can see that the information
is being displayed
next up here instead of displaying call
to action message I'm going to display a
explore programs message so let's go
back to our vs code
let me just say explore
programs here
and then lastly
instead of this message here
I want to display the message or get
certified get ahead without programs so
back in our vs code
I'm just gonna get rid of this
[Music]
and paste this instead
foreign
have a look at the browser
Let me refresh this
you can see it displays the message gets
certified get ahead and all of that
uh well now what I'm going to do is I'm
really not happy with the font size and
everything so I'm just go ahead and add
certain styling you can customize this
and provide your own font size and all
of that so here I'm just gonna mention
Style
and then say font size
and I'm going to make it XX large
all right so let's see
[Music]
yeah all right so it's the font size has
increased so I think I'm happy with this
all right so the next thing we have to
do is add information here for our
courses
so back in RVs code
we'll have to go to the courses
component so here I'm gonna just type in
the code for the different courses so I
already have it here so the first thing
is this message that I want to display
let me just copy that
and for our first tag I'm just gonna say
postgraduate program and lean Six Sigma
and the next information I'm going to be
providing is the duration
so here let me just get rid of this
face that here
let me just break the line
to beautify the code and then
and here for our reference link I
already have the link here
so I'm just going to paste that so once
you click on the more info button it
will automatically navigate to this page
all right
so let me see this
next up I'm going to do the same for the
other two courses as well
foreign
[Music]
in full stack development
and then we're going to mention the
duration and the cohort so
let me paste that
and also provide a line break
and then link I have it here so
I'm just gonna paste that
[Music]
and finally for the third card I have
the third link here
[Music]
let me get rid of this extra core and
paste this instead
[Music]
and then let's also provide the link for
the same
all right so uh let me save this
and have a look at the browser
so you can see that uh the information
has been added you can see it displays
postgraduate program in lean sex Sigma
full stack development and cyber
security so once I click on more info it
leads you to that page that shows the
overview all right
so now the next thing on the agenda was
to display a short video and then the
link to our YouTube channel so let's go
ahead and add that in our
cautious component
so what I'm going to do is I'm just
going to get the code to add a video
from Google and then I'm going to
provide the source which is going to be
the video that I would want to display
so I've received the code I'm just going
to paste it here
so you can get the code uh on Google so
go ahead and just paste that also for
the source I have a video in my assets
folder which I have provided here
so when I save it and look at the
browser here we go you can see the video
here
all right
and once clicked it starts playing
[Applause]
[Music]
all right and lastly we'll have to
provide the logo for YouTube and then
the link to navigate to the YouTube page
so let's go ahead and do that
so here again I've pasted the code
for the YouTube logo so here you can see
that I've added the image that is
YouTube dot PNG in my assets folder and
I've provided the source
and accordingly I've also added
The Styling I've provided a white
background and I've also aligned the
text to the center of the page
all right and I've also displayed the
message saying check out our YouTube
channel for technical videos and
tutorials
and then I provided the link to our
Channel on YouTube so let me just save
this and head back to the browser
and here you can see that
we have the YouTube logo
and we have the message displayed so
once you click on the
logo it navigates to the simply learned
Channel on YouTube
all right so uh if you want you can also
change the message here for the footer
so here in footer.html I can just
remove this and
paste this I say simply on Solutions and
All Rights Reserved and I save it and
look at the browser
it must get updated
so yeah there we go
so with the help of bootstrap we have
successfully created a website which is
basically a Blog
and we've also added the reference links
and images and logos to customize it
according to our requirements
so yeah this is it this is how you make
use of bootstrap and embed it into your
angular for more responsive and better
user interface let's have a look at the
basics of routing
now I'm sure that you've observed that
the URL changes every time you click on
a particular link or on an icon on the
user interface correct now this
basically indicates that you are
navigating throughout the application
now to achieve this navigation we use a
mechanism called routing routing is
essentially used to navigate through a
website or a web application
but how is it achieved in angular
especially in angular routing plays a
major role it is used to create a single
page applications now these applications
are loaded just once and new content is
added dynamically applications like
Google Facebook Twitter and Gmail are a
few examples of single page applications
the best part of using single page
applications is that it provides an
excellent user experience and you don't
even have to wait for new pages to load
which by extension makes single page
applications extremely fast but how is
this new content loaded
enter routing now routing is the
mechanism that as discussed earlier that
is used to navigate through the
application and load new content
routing helps angular configure the
route and the component that needs to be
displayed
now I'm sure you're going to understand
the concept of routing better when you
work on it Hands-On
so in the demo we're going to be
navigating to the login and the home
pages of a web application with the help
of routing
so let's head to our Visual Studio code
so basically the objective of our
application is to navigate to home and
the login pages so when I click on the
login icon here it loads the login page
and here you can see the extension
slash login and similarly with home once
you click on it some new information
gets added and the URL changes
with a slash home appended all right so
this is the main objective of our
application so to create it let's head
back to our vs code all right so here
I've created a folder called demo and
underscore angular and I've created a
file called demo routing
now the first thing you want to do is
open the index.html file and make sure
that the base tag is added now although
this is generally added when your app is
created if it is not then add a base tag
with href attribute which is set to a
forward slash
all right now this is generally done to
tell angular to construct the URL while
navigating with a forward slash all
right and the next thing you want to do
is open your app dot module.ts file and
check if the app routing module has been
imported
if not go ahead and import it and then
also mention it in your Imports array
or with that or the initial setup is
done
Now to create the nav bar the code that
I'm going to be using is already
explained in the previous video that is
angular bootstrap I highly suggest you
go through that video before watching
this
so uh the code is already available I'm
just going to create a component and
write the code for it and paste the code
in it so let's do that
let me say NG g c
NAB bar
[Music]
or as a this component is now created
now here in my HTML file
I'll just get rid of this and paste the
code for the nav bar
so here we go I've pasted the code for
the navigation bar
and back in my
app.component.html file I'll just remove
all The Unwanted code here
and just specify the
custom HTML tag for my nav bar
so let me just create one here
all right let me save this let me just
run the application and see if it's
displaying correctly all right so when I
open the browser uh the navigation bar
has been created
along with these different options
that's home about services and login
all right and we also have the simply
learn icon here all right now the next
step is to generate the components to
display the login page content and the
home page content
now again I have used bootstrap to
define the user interface for these
files you can easily find the code
online just search for a bootstrap login
templates and depending on your
requirements you can choose the
appropriate one
so first let's create the components for
by two files that is for the home
component
and the login component
so
let's go ahead and do that
[Music]
nggc
I'm just going to call it login for my
login component
all right and then I'm gonna say nggc
home for the home component
all right
so I'm just going to copy the code for
the login component
so back in my login.html
file
I'll just paste the code here
okay
also note that I've added the simply
learn logo in my assets folder
and then just provided the source for it
here in my login component
all right
so next up is the home component
and if you've seen the previous video
that is angular bootstrap you might have
seen that we created three different
components that is intro courses and
footer which included the content for
the intro message for the courses and
the footer message correct so here we're
going to just paste the code for all of
these three
and then just display it when the home
button is clicked
all right so what I'm going to do is
I'll just paste it here
[Music]
so this basically has all the content
one thing I want to tell you is that in
the previous video we made sure that the
code was written in three different
components however for this I've just
added all the code in the same component
now I agree that this is not the best
practice so if you want you can go ahead
and create three different components
and separate the code into these three
components and just add the custom HTML
tags in your home component
I'm just hoping you're uh following me
right now and also here in my assets
folder I have added a video and the
YouTube logo that needs to be displayed
uh when the home icon is clicked all
right so now that we've created the home
and the login components the next step
is to configure the routes for the
application right so here you can see
that we have a file called app routing
module.ts file
so here we have the routes and the
router module that is imported and we
also have a constant called routes which
is strongly typed two routes from the
router package
all right now this array is used to
define all the possible routes in the
application now each route is basically
an object with a path
so here in my routes array I'm just
going to go ahead and create the paths
that is we have two different uh routes
right one is for login and one is for
home
so I'm just going to create a path
object so let's say path
sorry within curly braces I say path
[Music]
and then the path that I'm going to give
is login
this is basically what will appear uh on
the URL all right and the component that
needs to be
navigated to is nothing but the login
component
so let me just say login
component as you can see the login
component has been automatically
imported
now same with
uh the Home Path so let me just say
but
home
and the component that needs to be
rendered is the home component
[Music]
all right
now the next step is to link these
routes to a button
in the navbar that is the home and the
login button right so we're going to
make use of the nav tag and an anchor
tag for this
you can see that we have a nav tag
and an anchor tag
which encloses the login and the home
components
all right now we're going to make use of
two directives from the router package
called router link and router link actor
now these are specified within the
anchor tag the router link basically
holds the path to the page
and the latter that is the router link
active specifies one or more CSS classes
that will be applied when the router
link is active
all right so to do that let me just add
router
link
all right in our case it is home here
and we're gonna have another directive
called router link active
[Music]
and we're just gonna say active here
all right
same for the login icon here
and you just copy this
[Music]
and instead of home
the path we created for this was login
[Music]
all right
so this is how you can bind the route to
your specific button on your UI
now despite of all this how are we
specifying where these components are to
be displayed
right the answer to this is using the
router Outlet director now again this
directive is available in the router
package so we have to add that in our
app component.html file
so here just go ahead and type
router Outlet
all right so with that we've created a
simple navigation bar which has
different options that is home about
services and Link and once the user
clicks on the home icon it displays the
content that is in the home
component.html file and once the user
clicks on the login component it
displays the content in the login.html
file all right it's as simple as that so
now let's go to the browser and see if
it executes correctly
so all right we have the navigation bar
and once I click on the home icon here
all right yes we see that all the
content has been loaded
you can see we have uh the intro section
we have the courses section and the
footer section as discussed
and the most important part is that here
in our URL you can see that slash home
has been appended this shows that a
route has been created that navigates to
the home component so we've successfully
created a route here
and for login component when I click on
this icon you can see that the path
changes here and the login component
gets displayed
all right so this is how routing is
achieved in angular choose from over 300
in-demand skills and get access to 1 000
Plus hours of video content for free
visit skillup by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
in this session we'll be comparing the
three Cutting Edge UI development
technologies that is react JS angular
and view we learn about the key
differences that make them so distinct
all of these technology Stacks have been
replacing pure server-side Technologies
and we've slowly progressed from
server-side applications to more
distributed applications where a part of
the job is done on the client side and a
part on the server side and now we've
transitioned to something on a single
page applications or spa and all of
these technologies that you see on your
screen right now are based purely on
JavaScript as a result their lightweight
and aren't dependent on any third-party
runtime tools so let's compare the three
Technologies and learn about the factors
that make them stand out so let's see
what's in it for you we learn about
their features use cases and whether
replied the performance how they handle
data the languages they use and the
testing mechanisms we learn about the
dedicated user community that backs
these Technologies and finally we'll see
the growth curve first we'll look into
the Salient features now react is a
front-end JavaScript library while
angular and view are JavaScript
Frameworks now although the terms
library and Frameworks are used
interchangeably they're significantly
different now Library G is a set of
classes or functions and the user is in
complete control to call them Frameworks
on the other hand are like models they
have limited choices and come with a
blueprint of their own and as a result
the user doesn't have much control so
JavaScript being an interpreted language
where code is executed line by line
makes all these tools very efficient
mainly because converting the code into
an intermediate code would require a
runtime environment and would definitely
encounter a delay now these are avoided
and as a result these tools are fast
moving on react is used to develop
mobile and web applications and angular
is used for single bit applications and
you can also develop hybrid applications
using the stack mainly because it's
purely based on CSS HTML JavaScript and
jQuery single page applications as the
name suggests are built using single
page now the entire page is broken down
into several components wherein each
component performs a specific task say
for example one component handles the
login the other one would display icons
and images and so on all these bits or
components are then put together to form
a single page application and moving on
react was developed and maintained by
Facebook while angular was built by
Google and view was developed by Avenue
and X Google employee now react
represents the view part of the MVC
framework and angular is a full-fledged
MVC framework in itself and view on the
other hand is focused on view and the
model layer of the MVC framework now
what exactly is the MVC framework now
MVC framework is a object oriented
design principle that mandates the
separation of control meaning one thing
can only do one thing so the model deals
with the entity classes the data and the
business logic while view deals with the
representation and the UI logic of the
application and the controller drives
the functionality of the two any changes
can be easily factored and isolated and
as a result testing becomes a whole lot
easier moving on now let's look at the
use cases from the business perspective
in terms of react we have top websites
like Facebook Instagram Netflix that use
react on the other hand we have angular
that is used by Nike HBO Forbes Sony and
view is commonly used by alibaba.com
grammarly 9gag and Adobe moving on we
have performance now performance is a
very crucial feature now the moment you
build an HTML View and render it into
the browser this view to the user is
basically just HTML tags however if you
look at the internal working the code is
actually converted into a balanced
restructure this B3 algorithm is
extremely fast so when the user makes
any changes to the UI the changes are
reflected immediately this is
facilitated by the B tree algorithm so
as a result the performance is improved
so how does react make use of this tool
it uses a virtual dom dom dom is an API
developed by w3c it stands for document
object model and defines how the
document is accessed and manipulated
this Dom passer converts the HTML code
into an inverse balance tree structure
so react uses the virtual Dom while
angular uses the real Dom and view uses
the virtual Dom again now the virtual
Dom looks at the differences between the
current and the previous HTML pages and
only changes the parts that need to be
updated angular on the other hand
updates the entire tree structure
regardless of any changes made or not
and view again only updates the ones
that have changed since there is no time
spent on making unnecessary changes to
the entire tree react is extremely fast
on the other hand real Dom updation is
time consuming risky and Aero Pro Vue
also ensures faster and buff free
performance now let's talk about data
binding the core reason why we would use
single the page applications now
consider a scenario where you log into
an e-commerce website as say user one
then you should be able to see the items
in your shopping cart while user 2 would
be seeing different items in their
shopping carts and so on so identifying
the user and retrieving data
corresponding to that specific user is
facilitated using the help of data
binding data binding is a process that
allows an internet user to manipulate
web page elements using a web browser
now it is used in interactive components
such as calculators tutorials Games Etc
now react supports one-way data binding
meaning you can take the data from The
View and push it to the model or vice
versa angular on the other hand uses a
two-way data binding while view also
uses a similar two-way data binding in
react every time the model State updates
The View changes accordingly however the
reverse is not true in case of angular
any changes made to the view are
immediately reflected in the model part
of the architecture view follows the
same principle now this usually
influences the performance due to
one-way data ending react is modular and
fast improving the performance angular's
two-way data binding adversely affects
the performance and view on the other
hand performs according to the input
type moving on to scripting languages
react combines UI templates and
JavaScript logic resulting in a new
language called jsx so react only
requires the knowledge of JavaScript
angular uses templates again in HTML you
can also inject JavaScript code into
HTML using a clever implementation in
angular called directors so you can
create a class and then inject it into
HTML angular also does something better
you can also write code for an angular
application using a newer language
developed by Microsoft called typescript
it is a compiled language and is very
similar to Java and c-sharp in terms of
syntax now view again uses HTML base
template it uses HTML5 throughout for
the UI and the combination of JavaScript
for business logic all view templates
are valid HTML and can be passed by HTML
passwords let's move on to testing now
just as a framework or an API that is
developed by Facebook and is used to run
tests on react applications to ensure
that they are bug free now it is
embedded typically in every react
library and requires zero configuration
now angular on the other hand uses the
Jasmine framework now this framework
allows various functionalities to write
different kinds of test cases this also
ensures that the application is error
free The View CLI or the command line
interpreter has built-in options for
unit testing with the help of jest or
mocha now view typically has single file
components and hence these components
can be tested in isolation this makes it
modular and extremely fast now let's
talk about Community Support since all
these tools are open source they have a
large developer Community there are a
few popular GitHub repositories for
react such as react.js 101 react.js.org
and so on you can raise queries solve a
few and connect with the larger
Community that's working on react here
are a few repositories for angular view
also has a few popular repositories you
can commit download third plugins and
also explore these tags even deeper all
of them surely have a very happening
community at the time of writing there
were about 1 million repositories 5
million comets and 1 million issues with
respect to react here are the figures
for angular and here are the figures for
view according to npm stat over the past
two years there have been approximately
360 million react.js downloads there
have been around 38 million downloads
for angular and around 63 million
downloads for view now let's look at the
future scope learning a new technology
always comes with questions like what's
in it for me what's its growth potential
how far will it take me in my career and
so on so let's go ahead and see the
growth rate of react angular and view
according to Google Trends over the past
12 months react has been on a way faster
upper trajectory than angular and view
which have considerably lost their
momentum now this indicates that react
is growing faster than the other two
with respect to popularity industry
adoption and Community Support in
today's video we're going to learn about
angular 10. well you must be aware that
angular released a new version that has
angular version 10 in June of 2020. so
in this video we're going to talk about
the new improvements additions and
applications that come with angular 10.
so now let's look at what's in store for
us
first we'll look at the previous angular
versions
next we look at what's new with angular
and finally I'll let you know how to
update to angular 10. first off let's
have a look at the previous angular
versions
ever since its Inception angular has
been consistent with releasing new
features in their versions first up was
angular 1 then angular 2
4 however angular 3 was kept there was
angular 5 and angular 6 angular 7 8 9
and finally in 2020 they released
angular 10. angular 1.x also known as
angularjs was a JavaScript based open
source front-end web application
framework now it aimed at simplifying
both the development and the testing of
applications by providing a framework
for client-side model view controller it
aims to simplify both the development
and the testing of applications by
providing a framework for model view
controller and model view view model
architectures next up angular 2 was
released which was written entirely in
typescript angular 1.x was not built
with mobile support in mind whereas with
angular 2 it came with mobile support
now Angela 3 was kept
due to certain discrepancies with
angular 4 the release was made Backward
Compatible with two point x point x for
most of the applications now there was
no major change in angular 4 from
angular 2. next up is angular 5. now
angular 5 version concentrated on making
angular smaller and faster to use
HTTP client Library build Optimizer and
compiler improvements were made
with angular 6 the angular CLI was
released new commands like NG update and
NG add were introduced
now angular 7 released in October 2017
came with performance improvements and
some interesting features like CLI
prompts virtual scrolling and drag and
drops
with angular 8 that was released in 2019
features like Builder apis web worker
support and dynamic Imports to name a
few were introduced
also features like IV renderer and basil
were introduced moving on to angular 9
is this was released in February 2020.
now angular 9 came up with the most
awaited IV compiler now its advantages
for faster testing better debugging
improved CSS class and style binding
improved type checking improved build
errors improved build times and improved
internationalization
it came with better framework and
angular material and now the latest
version that is angular 10 was released
in June 2020
. so now let's look at the new features
of angular 10 a little deeply so what's
new with angular 10 first up older
versions of typescript are not supported
so the previous versions of angular
supported typescript 3.6 3.7 and 3.8 but
with angular 10 typescript was bumped to
the version 3.9 TS lib has been updated
to version 2.0 and TS lint has been
updated to version 6. next up is
warnings about common JS Imports now
logging of unknown property bindings or
Elements which were previously warnings
have been now increased to the error
level
this change may have an effect on tools
that are not expecting an error log the
most important update of all is that
version 10 offers a new strict project
setup when you create a new workspace
with the NG new command now generally
you have the NG new project name command
however you can have additional setting
that is engineer strict setting this
flag initializes your new project with
few new settings that improve
maintainability help you catch bugs
ahead of time and allow the CLI to
perform Advanced optimizations on your
application
specifically the strict flag does The
Following it enables strict mode in
typescript
it turns template type checking to
strict it configures your app to be side
effect free
next up is the ngcc feature
now with angular 10 there has been an
implementation of a program based entry
point finder so what exactly is an entry
point finder now this is a point where
the first instructions of a program are
executed and this indicates that the
program has access to the command line
arguments so with angular 10 this
feature has been implemented using a
program-based entry point finder now
this is designed to only process entry
points that can be reached by a program
defined by your config.json file next up
is compiler update
in the latest angular version a compiler
interface has been added in order to
wrap the actual ngtsc compiler
angular version 10 has added name spans
for property reads and Method calls next
up is URL routing updation well
returning null from a URL matcher would
throw the type null is not assignable to
type URL match result before
this is fixed but the return type can
now be null too
next up is deprecated apis
now angular 10 has seen deprecation of
esm 5 bundles which saves up to 120 MB
of download and install time while
running Beyond or npm install for
angular packages and libraries
we will also see a deprecation of older
browsers including Internet Explorer 9
10 and Internet Explorer mobile that are
based on heavy consultation with the
community next up is bug fixes
with this angular 10 version there have
been a number of bug fixes that includes
compiler avoiding undefined expressions
in an array the core avoiding a
migration error when a non-existent
symbol is being imported now another
crucial bug fix ensures proper
identification of modules affected by
overrides in test bed next Improvement
is no default browser configuration Now
browser configuration for new projects
have been updated to outdo older and
less used browsers one simply has to add
the required browsers in the dot browser
list file to enable es5 builds and
differential loading for browsers next
up is core
all the warnings will now be locked in
as errors now generic has been made
mandatory for module with providers the
next Improvement is converting free IV
code
now all the pre-iv dependencies from nbm
should be transformed to IV dependencies
now this is supposed to take place as a
precursor for running ngtsc at the
application and lastly we have service
workers
now in the previous versions there were
situations where the service worker
never got registered when there was a
long running task or a recurring timeout
however this error has been fixed in
this version
well if you've worked extensively with
angular over the past couple of years
and have now updated to the new version
then these improvements are way more
visible so for the ones who haven't
updated let me tell you how to update to
angular 10. now you can go back to your
command prompt
and here run the command
Ng
update
at angular
CLI
and at angular slash core
now this must update your version to
angular 10 it installs all the packages
for tooling this might take a while and
once the installation is complete you
can go ahead and check for the version
just type in the command NG hyphen
version and there you go it says version
10.0.4 in this video I present to you
some commonly asked angular interview
questions
now let's begin I've classified the
questions into two sections one is the
beginner level questions and one is the
advanced level questions
so now let's begin with beginner level
questions
starting with the most basic what
exactly is angular
now angular is an open source JavaScript
front-end framework which is completely
written in typescript this framework
brings a structure and consistency to
web applications and provides excellent
scalability and maintainability
now it's primarily aimed to develop
single page applications and is
maintained by Google
it uses HTML syntax to express your
application's components clearly it is
designed for web desktop and mobile
platforms
next up is what exactly is typescript
now typescript is a superset of
JavaScript that offers excellent
consistency
it is highly recommended as it provides
some syntactic sugar and makes the code
base more comfortable to understand and
maintain ultimately typescript code
compiles down to JavaScript that can run
efficiently in any environment
now typically typescript is installed as
an npm package and thus can be installed
with the following command that is npm
install hyphen G typescript
moving on to our third question what
exactly is data binding and which type
of data binding does angular deploy
now data binding is a phenomenon that
allows any internet user to manipulate
web page elements
now it generally uses Dynamic HTML and
does not require any complex scripting
or programming
we use data binding in pages that
contain interactive components such as
forms calculators
tutorials and games data binding makes
incremental display of a web page more
convenient
when it comes to angular it uses the
two-way data binding any changes made to
the user interface are reflected in the
corresponding model state
conversely any changes in the model
state are reflected in the UI state
this allows the framework to connect the
Dom to the model data via the controller
next question what are single page
applications
now single page applications are web
applications that load just once with
new features just being mere additions
to the user interface
it does not load new HTML pages to
display the content instead it's
generated dynamically
this is made possible through
javascript's ability to manipulate the
Dom elements on the existing page itself
an Spa approach is faster thus providing
a seamless user experience
differentiate between angular and
angularjs
now here's a simple table for you so
here are the features that we're going
to differentiate the two on the basis of
first is language angularjs uses
JavaScript while angular uses typescript
when it comes to architecture angularjs
supports the model view controller
design while angular uses components and
directors angularjs is not supported by
mobile browsers
while angular supports all mobile
browsers
angularjs does not support dependency
injection while angular does
when it comes to routing at Route
provider is used to provide routing
information in the case of angularjs and
in case of angular at Route
configuration is used to define routing
information
when it comes to management angularjs is
difficult to manage with an increase in
source code size while angular is better
structured easy to create and can manage
bigger applications
next up what are decorators in angular
decorators are a design pattern or
functions that Define how angular
features work
now they're used to make prior
modifications to a class service or
filter
angular supports four types of
decorators namely class decorators
property decorators method decorators
and parameter decorators
next question mention some advantages of
angular first up is custom components
now angular enables users to build their
own components that can pack
functionality along with rendering logic
into reusable pieces
this is achieved with the help of these
components
data binding as discussed earlier
angular enables users to effortlessly
move data from JavaScript code to the
view and react to users events without
having to write any code manually
angular supports dependency injection
which enables users to write modular
services and inject them wherever they
need it
when it comes to testing tests are first
class tools and angular has been built
from ground up with testability in mind
you will have the ability to test every
part of your application and that is
highly recommended
next up is comprehensive angular is a
full-fledged framework and provides out
of the box solutions for Server
communication routing with your
application and more
lastly angular is cross-platform and
compatible with multiple browsers an
angular application can typically run on
all browsers be it Chrome Firefox Safari
and operating systems like Windows Mac
OS and Linux
what's new with angular 10. first up is
that older versions of typescript are
not supported previous versions of
angular supported typescript 3.6 3.7 and
even 3.8 but with angular 10 typescript
bumped to typescript 3.9
warnings about common JS Imports now
logging of unknown property bindings or
element names in templates is increased
to the error level which was previously
a warning
angular now supports an optional strict
setting which offers a stricter project
setup when you create a new workspace
there's an addition of ngcc features
with a program based entry point finder
there are common compiler updates
an updated URL routing
angular 10 has several deprecated apis
that were previously redundant
with angular 10 version there have been
a number of bug fixes important ones
being the compiler avoiding undefined
expressions and the core avoiding a
migration error
new default browser configuration
browser configuration for new projects
has been upgraded to outdo older and
less used browsers next up is code all
the warnings will be now logged in as
errors
next update is converting free IV code
now all the pre-iv dependencies from npm
should be transformed to IV dependencies
which is supposed to take place as a
precursor to running ngtsc at the
application
and lastly we have service workers for
the service worker a fix has been put in
for a situation in which there was a
chance that the service worker would not
register when there is a long running
task or a recurring timeout
next up is what are templates in angular
now angular templates are written with
HTML that contains angular specific
elements and attributes now in
combination with model and controller's
information these templates can be
rendered to provide a dynamic view to
the user now templates are a very
predominant feature of angular that
describe how information can be
displayed in The View
next question is what are annotations in
angular
now these annotations are used to create
an annotation array they are basically
the metadata set on the class that is
used to reflect the metadata Library
what are directives in angular
directives are attributes that allow the
user to write new HTML syntax specific
to their applications
now these execute whenever the angular
compiler finds them in the Dom
now again angular supports three
different types of directives there are
component directives attribute
directives and structural directors
next up what is aot compilation and what
are some of its advantages
now aots that stands for ahead of time
compiler basically converts the angular
HTML and typescript into JavaScript code
during the build phase that is before
the browser downloads and runs the code
so basically all the HTML and typescript
code is converted to JavaScript during
the build phase which means no
additional time is spent on converting
it into JavaScript later during the Run
phase right so when it comes to
advantages of course there's faster
rendering there are fewer asynchronous
requests it has smaller angular
framework download size this quick
detection of errors and this also offers
better security
moving on to the next question what are
components
now components are the most basic
building blocks of the UI in an angular
application
now every component is associated with a
template and is a subset of directives
only one component can be instantiated
per element in a template
now an angular application typically
consists of a root component which is
basically the app component and then it
branches out into other components
creating a hierarchy now every component
is decorated with the help of at
component decorator which provides
additional information
and component must belong to the NG
module
lastly components Implement something
called the life cycle hooks you will
learn about them a little later in the
video
next up what are pipes and angular
now pipes are simple functions that are
designed to accept a particular input
value process this value and return an
output which is a transformed value
now angular supports several built-in
pipes however you can also create custom
pipes that cater to your needs
but to speak about a few saline features
pipes are defined using the pipe symbol
pipes can be chained with other pipes
and pipes can be provided with arguments
by using the colon sign next up what are
pure pipes now these pipes are pipes
that use pure functions
as a result of this a pure pipe doesn't
use any internal State and the output
Remains the Same as long as the
parameters past stay the same angular
calls a pure pipe only when it detects a
change in the parameters being passed
now a single instance of a pure pipe is
used throughout all components
next up what are impure pipes
now for every exchange detection cycle
in angular
these impure pipes are called regardless
of the change in the input fields as
long as there's a change detected these
pipes are called
as a result multiple pipe instances are
created for these pipes
now inputs passed to these pipes can
also be mutable
by default all pipes are pure however
you can also mention impure pipes using
the pure property now here's a code for
specifying impure pipes you can use the
pure property and either mention true or
false true meaning it's a pure pipe and
false indicates that it's an impure pipe
next up what is the pipe transform
interface
as the name saves an input value
and transforms it into the desired
format with a transform method
it is typically used to implement custom
pipes now here's again a small piece of
code now you can see that the pipe
transform interface is being used which
in turn
executes the transform method now this
transform method is the one that is
responsible to change your input and
give a transformed output
moving on what is NG module
now NG modules are basically containers
that reserve a block of code to an
application domain or a workflow
now the at NG module takes a metadata
object that describes how to compile a
components template
and generate an injector at runtime in
addition to this NG module also
identifies the module's components
detectives Services pipes and also
ensures that it makes them public so
that external components can use them
all of this is taken care of by the NG
module
next up what are filters in angular
now filters are used to format an
expression and present it to the user
they can be used in view templates
controllers or services
now to name a few there's
date filter which formats a date to a
specified format
there's filter filter that selects a
subset of items from an array there's
the Json filter which formats an object
to a Json string there's limit 2 which
limits an array or a string into a
specified number of elements or
characters
then there's lowercase which formats a
string to lower case and so on
moving on to the next question what is
view encapsulation in angular
foreign
capsulation basically defines whether
the template and styles defined within
the component can affect the application
or vice versa
angular provides three encapsulation
strategies
this emulated encapsulation which means
that the styles from the main HTML
propagate to the component then there is
native which indicates that the styles
from the main HTML do not propagate to
the component meaning it does not affect
the component and lastly there's none
which means that styles from the
component propagate back to the main
HTML and therefore are visible to all
the components on the page now this
indicates any different types of changes
and how it is affecting the entire
application
moving on what are controllers now as
the name suggests controllers control
the data of angular applications their
regular JavaScript objects and the NG
controller directive defines the
application controller
next question what do you understand by
scope in angular
now the scope and angular binds the HTML
that is basically the view and the
JavaScript that is the controller it is
also an object with the available
properties and methods required for your
application
now when you make a controller an
angular you pass the dollar scope object
as an argument
moving on to the most commonly asked
question explain the life cycle hooks in
angular
as discussed earlier every component and
angular has a life cycle
angular creates and renders these
components and also destroys them before
removing them from the document object
model it is achieved with the help of
these life cycle hooks now let's have a
look at them first up is NG on changes
now this responds when angular sets or
resets data bound input properties
NG on it
is a hook that initializes the directive
or a component after angular first
displays the data bound properties and
sets the component's input properties
NG do check detects and acts upon the
changes that angular can't or won't
detect on its own
NG after content in it responds after NG
projects external content into the
components View
NG after content checked response after
angular checks the content projected
into the component
NG after viewing it responds after
angular initializes the component's
views and child views
NG after view checked responds after
angular checks the component's views and
the child views
lastly there's NG on Destroy which
cleans up just before angular destroys
the directive or the component
moving on to the next question what is
string interpolation in angular
now string interpolation is a one-way
data binding technique that is used by
angular now it outputs the data from
typescript code to HTML View
it is typically denoted with the help of
curly braces and it helps display data
from the component to the view to help
you understand it's working I've created
a variable called name here in my
app.component.ts file and initialize it
to Simply on and back in my HTML file
I've created
a heading tag a header tag which
displays the name of the company is and
I have interpolated here with the help
of double curly braces so when I run the
file the output looks something like
this the name of the company is simply
learn so this is how string
interpolation is achieved in angular
moving on to next question what are
template statements
template statements are properties or
methods used in HTML
for responding to user events now with
these template statements the
application that you create or you're
working on can have the capability to
engage users through actions such as
submitting forms or displaying Dynamic
content most common example is the
button tag the template here is delete
hero this method is called when the user
clicks on the button
so this brings interactivity to your
application
with that we come to the end of the
first section which included the
beginner level questions
moving on let's look at some advanced
level questions
what is the difference between ahead of
time and just in time compilation
now ahead of time compilation converts
your code during the build time before
the browser downloads and runs the code
in case of just in time compilation this
process is a way of compiling computer
code to machine code during the
execution phase
aot ensures faster rendering to the
browser while just in time is basically
a dynamic compilation
in case of ahead of time compiling the
user should include The Hyphen hyphen
aot option with the NG build or NG sub
command
and jit compilation is the default
compilation when you run the NG build or
NG serve CLI commands
next up explain the at component
decorator
now here's a simple screenshot of what
that component decorator encompasses
this is it is basically a typescript
class that is used to create
components
this genre of class is then decorated
with the at component decorator
the decorator's purpose is to accept a
metadata object that provides relevant
information about the component
now the image above shows an app
component which is a pure typescript
class decorated with that component
decorator
the object that gets accepted by The
Decorator provides properties like
template URL selector style urls
and many more now here the template URL
property points to an HTML file defining
what you see on the application
moving ahead what are services in
angular angular services
perform tasks that are used by multiple
components
now these tasks could be data fetching
network connections or database
management among others
they perform all the operational tasks
for the components and avoid rewriting
of code
the service can be written once and then
injected into all the components that
use it
generally components are used to only
display information on the UI they do
not perform any other back-end tasks to
perform tasks like validating
information or network connections Etc
you can make use of a service one
advantage is that this service can be
injected into multiple components that
make use of the same piece of code with
this you can avoid redundancy
moving on what are promises and
observables now while both the
components deal with asynchronous events
in angular
promises handle one such event at a time
while observables handle a sequence of
events over some time
so to give you a brief explanation
promises emit a single value at a time
while Observer this are only executed
when subscribed to them using the
Subscribe method
now promises also execute immediately
after they are created and they're not
cancelable
while observables help perform
operations like for each filter retry
Etc promises push errors to the child
promises and observables can be
unsubscribed to so that the listener
stops receiving further values
next up what is NG on in it and how is
it defined
now again here's a small snippet of code
NG on init is a life cycle hook as we
discussed earlier and there is a
callback method that is run by angular
to indicate that a component has been
created
takes no parameters and returns a void
type
so I'm sure you can see here in the code
it takes no parameters and returns a
void
next up explain the use of ng4 in a tag
or explain the ng4 directive
now the ng4 directive is basically like
a for Loop it is used to build lists and
tables in HTML templates
so in simple terms this directive is
used to iterate over an array or an
object and create template for each such
element
now in the snippet you can see there is
let items and item list and then I have
string interpolated the variable item so
let item here creates a local variable
that will be available inside the
template
of items indicates that we are iterating
over the items iterable
and the asterisk before ng4 creates a
parent template
next up what are template and reactive
forms so there are two different methods
to create forms we have the template
driven approach and we have the reactive
form approach so let's have a look at
them
in case of template driven approach the
conventional form tag is used to create
forms angular automatically interprets
and creates a form object representation
for this tag controls can be added to
the form using the NG model tag
multiple controls can be grouped using
the NG control group module
now a form value can be generated using
the form dot value object and form data
as exported as Json values
basic HTML validations can be used to
validate the form fields in the case of
custom validations directives can be
used
when it comes to reactive forms this
approach basically revolves around data
flows and propagation of change
now with reactor forms the component
directly manages the data flows between
the form controls and the data models
reactive forms are code driven unlike
template driven approach
reactive forms break the traditional
declarative approach and eliminate the
anti-pattern of updating data via the
two-way data binding method
typically reactive form control creation
is synchronous and can be unit tested
with synchronous programming techniques
moving on what is bootstrap how is it
added to angular
now bootstrap is a powerful toolkit it
is a collection of basic HTML CSS and
JavaScript tools for creating and
building responsive web applications
there are two ways to embed bootstrap
libraries
first up is using the bootstrap CDN
which is the content delivery Network
now this enables users to load the CSS
and JavaScript files remotely from its
servers
the other way is to use angular
bootstrap via npm
now this is used to add bootstrap to
your angular project by installing it
into your project folder now you can use
commands like npm install bootstrap and
npm install jQuery to install them for
your project if you wish to learn
bootstrap in detail I highly suggest you
check out our video on angular bootstrap
the tutorial explains how to embed
bootstrap and use it to create and good
looking angular applications
what is eager and lazy loading
eager loading is a default module
loading strategy now all the feature
modules under Eagle loading are loaded
before your application even starts this
is typically used for small size
applications since lesser modules are
used all of these modules are loaded
initially which makes running of these
kind of applications extremely fast
when it comes to Lazy loading all the
loading happens dynamically all feature
modules are loaded on demand
it is used for bigger applications where
the modules are not required at the
start of applications
this makes the application faster since
no time is spent on loading unnecessary
modules
next up what type of Dom does angular
implement
Dom or document object model treats an
XML or HTML document as a tree structure
in which each node is an object
representing a part of the document
now Angela uses the regular Dom this
updates the entire tree structure of
HTML tags until it reaches the data that
has to be updated
now to ensure that the Speed and
Performance are not affected angular
implements something called as a change
detection
next up how is dependency injection
achieved in angular
now dependencies are objects or services
that a component needs to perform
functions correct now with the help of
dependency injection these classes can
request dependencies from external
sources rather than creating them on
their own here I've created a service
called demo service using the command
ngg service demo service
and I've also added a small snippet of
code when you create that service
now these Services can be injected to
your main component and perform various
functions
next up how does angular routing work
now I'm sure you must have observed that
the URL changes every time you click on
your user interface on an application
correct every time you navigate through
the application or move from one page to
another the URL changes now this means
that the application is being routed or
you're navigating through the
application so basically routing helps
navigate through a web application
especially in case of single page
applications now as discussed earlier
single page applications are loaded just
once so any new content that is being
displayed is just a mere addition it's
not being loaded again so routing plays
a vital role in case of single page
applications
typically it is specified with the help
of the forward slash and followed by a
path that defines a new content
now I'm just taking the same example
that I took before uh this was the
example for string interpolation however
you can see that we have a navigation
bar here with four different options for
that is home about services and login
and for home and login I've created a
path and added routing to it so when I
click on the home icon you can see that
some content is being displayed onto the
screen and if You observe you can see
that there is a forward slash with the
path name home here which indicates that
routing has occurred same with login
when I click on it the path changes and
the login page appears if you wish to
learn the concept of routing I suggest
you check out a video the tutorial
explains routing in detail
moving on what are form control and form
groups
now a form control is basically a class
that enables validation
for each input field an instance of this
class is created
and these instances help check the
values of the field and see if they are
touched untouched dirty pristine valid
invalid or so on so for every field in
the form
the data that is being provided is
validated with the help of these
controls if it is dirty it means that
the value has been changed if the data
provided holds good for a particular
condition then the control is said to be
valid and so on with the help of these
controls you can determine if the value
provided is legitimate or not this can
be achieved with the help of form
control
when it comes to form group
and the form group class represents a
group of controls now from can have
multiple control groups the form group
class returns true if all the controls
are valid and also provides validation
errors if any next up is how is testing
achieved in angular
now Anglia uses Jasmine to run various
tests
the Jasmine framework allows various
functionalities to write different kinds
of test cases
the task runner for these tests is
typically Karma
and Karma uses a configuration file to
set the startup reporters and the
testing framework
next question is what is package.json
now npm installs package.json when a new
workspace is created
now this file includes a starter set of
packages some of which are required by
angular
now typically it's organized into two
groups one is dependencies these are
essential to run your applications and
we have Dev dependencies these are
essential to develop applications this
is an above and in this video we will be
creating a angularjs project but before
we jump to the coding part if you
haven't subscribed to our Channel
already make sure to hit the Subscribe
button and press the Bell icon so you
will never miss any update from Simply
learn so without further Ado let's see
how our application will look like at
the end of this video
so let me show you however application
will look like
so
like this our application will look like
here you can add anything like like
share
and comment
you can also remove it or Mark has done
like this you just have to click
and just remove if you want
from here you can just write anything
and just add or like this if it's done
or do you want to remove it
so
before we jump to the coding part let me
just tell you about a angular overview
so what is angular angular is an open
source JavaScript framework written in
typescript
Google maintains it and its primary
purpose is to develop single page
applications as a framework
angular has clear advantage while also
providing a standard structure for
developers on a team to work with it
enables users to develop large
application in a maintainable manner
so there are so many advantages
using angular but the two I love the
most is data binding and browser
compatibility
you can also check out our videos on
angular for deep understanding
so what is data binding angular enables
user to effortlessly move data from
JavaScript code to view and react to
user and events without having to write
any code manually
and the browser compatibility as angular
is a cross-platform and compatible with
multiple browsers and angular
application can typically run on any
browsers for example Chrome Firefox and
others such as Windows Mac OS and Linux
so let's open our
Visual Studio code
let's cut this
the first thing we're gonna do is we're
gonna create an angular project
for that let's open our command prompt
in this command prompt we'll write a
command
npm
install
I think globally
at
angular
CLI
press enter
so for this you must have node.js and
npm install in your system
it'll take a couple of seconds to
install the files
let's wait a minute
meanwhile
let me tell you why we use angular
JavaScript is the most commonly used
client-side scripting language it is
written in HTML documents to enable
interaction with web pages in many
unique ways as it is relatively easy to
learn language it is well suited for
Developers for modern applications
let's wait a couple of seconds more
so whatever angular application is
installed
so now we're gonna create a project for
that
we're going to write NG new and the
project name here I'm gonna write
angular
app
press enter
we're gonna ask you a few steps
yes
I'm gonna type CSS
and it will install all the necessary
packages
let's wait a couple of seconds more
let's discuss some other things about
angular
JavaScript idle for developing single
page applications that we all know but
that requires modularity testability and
developers probability perhaps not
these days we have a variety of
Frameworks and libraries designed to
provide alternative Solutions
with respect to where front-end
Frameworks
angular addresses many if not all of the
issues developer face when using
JavaScript on its own so angular is the
best app or tool to develop applications
so angular is the one thing I love the
most
so let's wait more seconds
so
all the packages are installed
successfully
so now
let's now open our Visual Studio code
let's cut this
and inside this let's open our folder
you can check the path of the file where
you have installed this so in the my
system it's in the user
here
and angular wrap is here so I'm going to
open it
so
this is what
it will open so those more most of the
code we are going to do is in this
source file
so we're going to open this app
so let's delete this we're gonna not
need it and
our application
we don't need routing as well
and
now
let's open style.tss
let's
delete this
and let's write some Global styling
here
let's write margin
if it is zero
betting zero
OtterBox
and
fun family
let's save this file
and let's open index.html
so here it's
angular app
now let's just run this and see
how it's looking for that let's type
control and backtech
to open the terminal
or you can also go here
let me just first
zoom out a little
then new terminal
inside this
new terminal
I'm gonna write
in this earth open
let me show you
so we're gonna type yes
enter
let's wait a couple of seconds
so as it's saying
this can't compiled
so let me see the issue here
it's saying
most of the times the
app routing the file that I have deleted
so because this file is has been called
somewhere
because of this this error is coming
so I'm gonna go here
and see where this file is
called
so we're gonna remove this part
this
map routing module part
now let's save it
now
let's see where are the issues here
again
do the compiling
until it's being compiled
we're gonna see if
where are the
HD file the CSS component is empty
in this HTML only
the issue is coming so it must be in the
last of this yeah
let's remove this save this file
and as you can see it's compiled
successfully
we're gonna go again to a Wrangler
application
as you can see it's showing this store
to
create a new component we're gonna write
this command NG generate component and
the file or the project name
angular material for that we're gonna
write this command
and like this there are so many other
commands also
if you want to learn angular you can
just click on that and it will open the
angular Iota tutorial part
so we don't need that let's delete this
and the application that we have created
let's delete it also
let's minimize this
and let's work on our code
let's minimize this as well
we don't need components
so let's delete this file
let's delete this
and here we'll write up
it's
there
I'll use a twin tag
and inside this I'm gonna write
from
preload
let's save it and see on our browser
it's saying hello from simple
isn't it amazing
let's write here
angular
to do up
let's just save it
let's see angular 221
now
let's make it under editor
let's write this one
between this so we'll make this
under header
it's working fine
no
I'll create a component for that
I'll create
a new terminal in here I'll write
a command Ng
globally
component
components in that I'll write
two two
enter
so as you can see here
component inside this app
has been created under to do
so here as you can see
so many to do components and
TS file has been created a typescript
file
so everything looks good here we don't
need this file so we're gonna remove it
so
let's minimize this
and inside the components folder
HTML
let's delete it
and create a class
to do
inside this class
I'm gonna create another class
let's name it as to do
let's make this as to do's
and this has two
after that
I'll create a class of
ID
so that we can
fetch the numbers
L for the junk data I'll write zero
look at that
we'll write F class
content whatever we're gonna post inside
that
so I'm going to write content
and insert this I'm going to write
my
two two
after that
I need it there now we can create a
button
of class
delete
and then inside that I'm gonna write
oh
it's fine let's see in the browser
how it's looking
with a couple of seconds
and then read a code
so
first we're gonna call it inside this
okay
that's right amp
tutus
it's not fixing it
let me see
tool okay
let's first see in the modules that
should provide that two two component is
automatically as you can see here
the 2do component is automatically has
been imported in this
see the issue
let's first see the component name
inside this file
okay the component is app.22
that's why it's not fetching
let's
delete head now save it
compiled successfully zero my to-do and
remove button
let's move forward now
so this is fine but we need to Loop this
how many times
so because of that
we can't write it so many times for that
we're gonna do
create a array inside this to do
component
under this Constructor
now we can use angular
engine for that I'm gonna write title
here I'm gonna write
component
okay let's see
so let's save this file in will go back
to our
to do a company.html and inside this
we're gonna call this class
so the name of the class here is title
that's why
I'm calling this here
let's see
you will see to do
if we'll change this to
to amp now let's save this
it will show us to do app
okay so this is how we can inject our
variables inside the Dom
so now
let's
delete it
tools
it's here
now let's save this
let's compile
I really inside this file only
title
so we have created an area
so let's create a file because we don't
want to access it from here so we
create a file let's name it as
to do
well let's
models first
let's just create a folder first
inside these models
will create a file
you
to
DOT type script
inside this we'll explore class
to do
here
if the content
but
freeing
and
it'll get completed
we'll get cool
so
as you can see here
intent
and
so yes oh
sign
it's looking fine now let's save this
file
let's move forward
let's first import
go to
we'll import this module
to dot TS file
so let's in this
tutor
from
tag
modules one to do
this is the path of this
so let's
filter
save this
and you have to write
doodle array
components are done
so we will
this is a keyword so
this
array
insert this
here I will write content
let's
it's true
complete
completed
okay it's
content
is what we are going to show so it's
Commander
okay
so let's content
and here we'll write
true
so it's
fine
we'll create two so we copied from here
paste it under there
it looks
let's say this the error is coming
can't fetch it so I guess the
reason behind it is
it's changing
yeah
let's save this still
compilation error is coming
deleted
let's try similar only
we're gonna have to work on our codes
let's minimize this
now
here we'll call it function
attribute for the asterisk
equals to
let
to do
he goes
and then let
I equals to
index
and next
so this looks
fine save it
so
two
so it can't fit it so you know
as the index here
it's not fetching
oh
okay we have declared here
as I as in x i
let's save it quite successfully
one okay fine
before we go deeper into the code
I'm gonna copy the CSS file
from here
let's copy this
and we're gonna paste that
component part
there are just simple CSS commands
we'll get this code in the description
box
let's save this
let's cut this
is not fetched
C
oh
mistake
these CSS should come under
Toto company.css let's save this
save and cut this also on this
now we'll open grab so our application
is going to look like this
is
buttons are not functional right now but
we'll make it functional
so let's
style it
remove will remain the same because it
is coming under the button part
now we're gonna call methods
and the methods are like just functions
okay
no
next
add
to do
it complete
when it will get complete
then Mark as done
otherwise
because
empty
so
it's done
it's completed
okay
let's see this
now
what we're gonna do is we're gonna make
method or function
so that whenever we click on this part
will just get cut or Mark as done
Sudan
I'm gonna go to this to the component
and under this
I'm going to create a method
toggle
done
and I'm gonna pass the ID
and inside this
this
dot map
don't worry I'm gonna tell you
how this is working and what I'm doing
it's not fetching V and I
just wait
where I'm gonna write
see
if
I is equals to equals to ID
P Dot
then
we'll get cut
or equals to
not V
Dot
dot completed
or if not
then return
V
so what I'm gonna do here is
okay this is
left
I'm gonna pass the number here
by the number
inside this ID
if things look
normal
let's find the issue here what's the
issue
okay
we have declared V and I but we can't
fetch it because it's under this only
so to
access this V and I here also
okay
check this let's
see
it's second and it's coming like this
let's go back to our code
and make this
calls only
let's make this also
this both are coming like this
okay
let's
to The Click function
side
and side over
component
EML okay
here only
clear click whenever we click on any
item
it will pass through dog
and here we're gonna pass
inside toggle hi so then we call this
we'll pass through I
save this
here also in the delete button
we're gonna do it later let's save it
first
see
whenever we click on this
LDL leader
like this
fine
let's just
go back to our code
after this we're going to create a
delete method
let's leave it as delete
this will implement
inside remove
like
so to delete
we will not write
again this to do
this
equals to
Dot to do
filter method
I will call V
V I can
stem will not repeat
old mistake
run right
not equals to
ID
when I is not equals to ID remove it
this is a function
so
we're going to call it like
we call inside our toggle done so we're
going to save this
going back to a cone
after this right click
when I will click
it will call
it
to do
and inside this will pass index
save this
coming back to our
component
let's just
create far
add to function
so let's first declare here the number
I have here
giving her number is
whenever will
put the number only that time it will
work
so we can't add a string here so that's
why we are declaring here
number
let's just delete this from now
save it and see
the remote function is also working now
going back to our code
what will need is
remove or ADD
so now we'll work on
let's let's create
first thing we're gonna do is
inside this
dot HTML
so we're not writing
two two
will help create a class
div
last name
doodles
and inside this
let's create a form
so this form will create input from the
user so what
he or she wants to enter in this
or first thing we'll need is the text
next we need is the name
and put
to
that please holder
inside that box that will
get created
all right
enter
your
after that you get the class
of
foot
to do
I have declared declared address to do
no your hand
let's
one thing I'm forgetting is the
NG model
will get red because
we are not
so this is coming red
because we haven't
created this input to do
the component so we're gonna create it
right now only
first here first let's just save this
okay
and let's
delete
okay
let's just delete this save this
it's coming red okay
let's
to do
is a string of
environment creating
what
will come under the string is
a Boolean only or not Boolean string
value only
let's open this
here
I'm gonna import
huh
Ng
module
triangular
code I guess
only module is already
fetched so we're gonna need
only
import
ant forms
module
angular
home
let's see this
hold it inside our
side over
app module
see yes
here we're gonna write
this module
with this app.word
even
um this
save as
so
I've called this one
so it's working now
this still is not working let's delete
this so everything is working fine now
nothing
and you can add
it's not adding
now everything is done
we're gonna
create
add two two
and insert this we will call this Dot
doodles
dot push it
content which will come under this will
be content
whatever comes under this
and two two
and then completed
then false
let's close this
and after this
let's create the empty string here
called
to do let's run this
app we are looking for
hello
from
being done
right click on its marking as done
we can also remove it
yeah and we can also add it
like
share
if this is Mark as done then click here
as done
okay
so with this we have reached the end of
this tutorial thank you for watching and
please subscribe to our Channel stay
tuned to Simply learn thank you
foreign
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here